Welcome back, master!
My lord!
Hello!
Hello, hello, hello.
Kept us waiting, huh?
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
I just ran to go get some...
Because my hot water was boiling.
I was like, maybe I can get some hot water before stream.
So, how are you feeling, Mito?
I'm... I'm okay.
I'm a little sleepy.
I'm on about...
One hour of sleep and then two hours of sleep.
So...
Hold on, I don't want to listen to Snake Eater just yet.
Said no one ever!
Just kidding, but I do want to talk a little bit until we listen to it.
No!
Wait!
Okay, there we go.
You're looking mintier than usual.
Is it my hair?
Why so little sleep?
Oh, well...
Because I...
Had an event today.
Vmuse in Malaysia.
And...
GMT plus 8, I think it is.
It's like literally opposite of me.
So, I had a meet and greet at...
Their time, 3.45pm.
But for me, it was 3.45am.
And...
During... Before... When I had to like wake up or stuff like that, I don't sleep the night before.
But my insomnia has been kind of bad recently anyway.
So...
I fell asleep around 2 and then I woke up at 3.
Oh boy, 3am!
And then after the meet and greet, I was really excited...
For meeting everybody.
That I couldn't fall asleep again.
Even though I didn't have to be up until...
6.30am.
So, I fell asleep at...
Like 5.30am.
And...
But I'm okay!
I'm alright.
I'm feeling okay.
Hopefully, I've slept...
I don't know, I slept a little bit.
Oh wait, so actually I slept also after the concert.
For about 2 hours.
So...
Isn't that like a thing though?
That people do?
Like an intermittent sleeping or something?
It's just me trying that out.
Micronaps.
Power nap gaming.
Some nap maxing.
I don't...
That's... Yeah, that's the scientific term.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nap maxing.
Yeah, but they tend to be crazy.
Oh, why is it blocked off?
There we go.
Thank you, Roden!
Love job early in the morning.
No!
Good luck with job tomorrow!
How would you feel knowing how many people you inspired to become Vtubers?
I mean...
I sell this to lots of people who are always just like...
You inspired me to do this or you inspired me to do this.
And I'm like... I mean...
But...
But ultimately... Sorry, I know I should probably...
I want to listen to Snake Eater.
I don't want to just go to the menu yet.
But ultimately, like...
It's up to... It's you who takes the first step, so...
You know, I don't feel like I really do anything.
So...
I'm just here playing Metal Gear Solid.
That's what I like to do.
You know it's serious when I'm drinking Energy Gamer Subs?
Hashtag...
Code Boomer for...
For a discount off your Gamer Subs order.
Code Boomer!
But I figured that maybe the tea wasn't enough.
So...
What flavor?
I like to mix the...
Non-caffeinated version of lemonade and then...
Another flavor.
Which just turns it into...
Flavor lemonade.
You know?
So...
Oh my gosh.
I got like...
I actually... I did like a...
What's it called?
Like a store-bought lemonade?
And then I mixed it with...
Oh no, it wasn't store-bought.
It was... Well, I mean, it was Wendy's Lemonade.
It was Wendy's Lemonade and I...
Forgot to ask for like a flavored lemonade.
And so I put in a Raspberry Gamer Subs into it.
It was so good.
It was actually so good.
Oh my gosh.
Minto making potions.
I know!
Did you try the Krabby Patty?
No!
Because it's like the most disappointing thing ever!
Right?
I hear everybody going to go get the Krabby Patty.
And...
It's not even a special packaging.
It's not even a special...
Like wrapping or any...
It's just a normal burger!
I feel like they flopped it hard.
Right?
Like...
I feel like they really didn't go...
As hard as they should have.
Total disappointment.
Yeah!
US sucks for tie-ins like this.
I know!
What a...
The boss equivalent for many VTubers still waiting for my Minto Gamer Subs.
One day I will get to meet and greet...
In the Midwest.
I hope so!
If you want to see me somewhere just to...
Well, right now I'm kind of taking a break from events.
Because I have some big stuff lined up for the end of the year.
But...
If you want to see me at an event...
Just talk to your local convention and say...
Hey, I would like to see Mint Phantom.
Yeah, yeah.
And the end of the month.
Yeah!
I have stuff at the end of the month.
Incidentally, Code Boomer is what they say over the intercom...
When you show up at conventions.
Shut up!
We got a Code Boomer.
Code Boomer here.
You just had to come out with a new outfit when I got done making the outfit for the Mint Dolphy Dream.
No, no, no!
Keiko, Keiko, Keiko!
You're okay.
Because my new outfit is basically...
My current outfit.
But with small, small changes.
Just small changes.
So, you should be okay.
You should be okay.
Just a tiny, tiny bit different.
I didn't want to make it so different that people didn't recognize me.
Yeah, the same, but different.
Spoilers?
How is it spoilers?
I've been saying this...
Did you guys watch the video?
He literally says...
A whole new outfit.
A whole new look, but not really.
He literally says that.
Oh, for the Vmuse thing, I did want to say...
If anybody got the streaming tickets...
I'm really sorry if there were...
If there were issues.
Yay, thank you.
Of course!
But...
If you were at the event, thank you for coming.
I feel really bad about...
Especially if people woke up really early...
To watch or something.
I'm so sorry.
Hopefully, they can...
Hopefully, they can get the VOD up...
Really soon.
Said they'll release the VOD or something at least.
Yeah, yeah, so...
I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry.
Mmm...
It was...
It was fun though.
It's 5AM for me, I'm so sorry.
How many loops of CQC theme was it at this point?
I don't know.
I'm trying to like wake up a little bit.
I'm trying to wake up a little bit, which is why I'm talking.
But, yeah.
Oh my gosh!
You know what?
Okay, yesterday I was supposed to stream this game.
But I didn't.
Because I instead...
I instead was like, okay, I'll rest.
Even though I didn't...
I like, couldn't sleep at all.
Maybe Corinnexit5 gets it!
But I also wanted to save my throat a little bit.
But...
My new display cabinet came.
It wasn't supposed to come until like mid next week.
But it came yesterday.
So I was able to put that together.
And put all my Metal Gear stuff in it.
And...
Sorry, I dropped my controller.
So...
Yeah!
It's actually like right behind me.
So I can turn around and look at it and be like...
Not all my Metal Gear stuff fits in it.
Like, I kept the books on the bookshelf.
I...
I'm just gonna press this.
Oh wait!
No!
Wait!
Sticky no!
Go back.
Wait!
No!
Back!
Okay.
But...
How was KLP48?
They were so cute!
They were so...
Oh my gosh, they were so cute!
They were so, so cute.
Books in a display cabinet.
No, no, no!
I kept them on the bookshelf.
Just kind of like...
Display-y stuff is in the display cabinet.
Boxcar!
Happy birthday, first of all!
Also, oh my gosh, I'm so jealous!
That sounds so fun!
Happy birthday to you!
Should I get a display cabinet for mint merch?
I don't think there is that much.
Okidoki.
Was V-Muser first time performing with an idol group?
Yes, it was!
It actually...
It was like an actual dream come true.
Like, I have a goals list.
And it's actually on there.
Ok!
Snake Eater time!
What a thrill With darkness and silence through the night What a thrill I'm searching and I'm melting to you What a fear in my heart But you're so supreme
I'd give my life, not for honor
Snake Eater In my time There'll be no one else I love the falling guys Crime is the way I fly to you I'm still in a dream Snake Eater
Some day, you'll go through the rain And some day, you'll feed on a tree frog This ordeal, the trial, to survive For the day we see new light I give my life, not for honor, but for you In my time, there'll be no one else Crime, it's the way I blight
I'm still in a dream, Snake Eater
I like the peace one.
Oh, I think I heard a little bit of a Sneater!
Alright, Sneater!
Sneater is real!
Let's go baby!
Alright So where we just left off was... We just left off from the whole torture sequence And we're about to escape Grozny Grad Only have the summer podcast acrylic standee, but I'm positive I'll be able to fill a cabinet eventually, right?
Right?
Let's keep releasing merch!
Okay, I'll try to have merch.
I'll try to have merch
Okay, Sunday, Mental Gear Mento 3, Maid Eater Yes, so true!
Alrighty
Okay, okey dokey.
We got nothing on us, we have a fork No, my Arbat!
Wait, could they eat this, maybe?
We can throw the Arbat for them to get sick.
I have a gun When did I get this?
Wait a second, why do I have...
Why do I have Ocelot's gun?
A boss gave it to me.
That's right!
Oh yes, yes, yes I don't think I ever...
I'm so tired, guys.
I don't think I ever noticed And we got our cigar and our camera.
Very big.
Important things Oh my gosh My vision!
My vision!
No!
Alright guys.
Oh, maybe... Wait, I don't have any camo or anything.
Okay I have Vampire Bat.
Tasted bad
Okay, I'm gonna have to get back into it Yeah, let's call everybody Snake, you're really gonna feel the cold with no clothes on
I'm naked.
I don't have any food.
What do you mean eat regularly?
Let's see
Okay Like a... Like what?
Make sure you keep eating It doesn't need to be clothes.
Anything you have that can cover...
Yeah, I know what you said Second, how do you feel about me being naked?
He said like tutorial mode
Second, didn't you see what I just went through?
He doesn't care at all Okay, alright, maybe Eva She's busy though, isn't she?
I know
Okay, I know where I need to go Yeah
I don't need directions to get to the manhole
This is Snake we're talking about
What's over here?
Wait, what's up here?
Oh my God, did someone just notice me?
Wait, I can't see.
Wait Go up, go up.
What a thrill.
What a thrill Don't notice me on the building Oh shit.
Oh shoot!
No, no, no, no!
Oh my God.
What the hell?
Oh that's right!
I can't CQC!
Oh my gosh, that's right That's right I think they noticed me Let's
see them.
Oh my God!
Eating this man first
Don't, don't, don't care about me guys I need a snack!
I need a snack!
You think if I jump down from the building... Oh my gosh, they're like...
They know I'm here, but they just miss every shot Silly guys Who's even here?
Who's
up here?
No way.
OK, I need to leave Bye!
Oh my God.
Snake, go!
Snake, just go!
Just go, Snake.
Just go Snake, just run.
Dodge, roll everywhere We know there's a little hole here
Oh my gosh, that's a rat
Yummy!
We're fine everybody Volgin doesn't need directions to the manhole either?
Not at all!
See guys, we're fine
Do you know about the easter egg?
If you don't remove the transmitter Transmitter?
Oh yes, I do know, but we'll keep it, we'll keep it, we'll keep it I want that part.
Yes, yes, I was like...
Yes, yes, I do know, I do know I do know, I do know We're gonna keep that scene, we're gonna keep that scene I thought you were trolling for a second My brain is very slow today Please understand, I'm so sorry If I am very... Today is mega silliness, ok?
We saw him last time.
Get her down!
At least they give you this, so you can at least shoot him, right?
Thanks for reading my tweet.
Crawlcatguy here Really wish I met you.
Wanted to bring my Snake cosplay out Ok, I should sleep.
Yes, please go to sleep!
Thank you for coming to see me!
I'm sad that we couldn't meet, but...
I saw you at the concert Come here, little rat Keep on eating, Snake
Yummy They're in caution mode, but they'll never find me Where are we?
Oh wait, I keep pressing this instead of this, ok
Oh, what?
We are kinda far Wait, ok
Let's just see where it leads us Just keep reading
What's here?
Oh my gosh, I can't see anything Where are we?
I think I should just run there, shouldn't I?
Just like, sprint There's nothing else here But I don't want people to walk into me, you know?
So let's just wait for 30 seconds Unhappy Anniversary Dough.
Hubob wet pants.
What does that mean?
Is she gonna eat Stuart Little?
I would.
I would eat Stuart Little This is survival!
This is survival!
You monster!
But he's sentient
Yeah Doesn't that make it a little bit more exciting?
He'd like, beg for his life.
He'd be like, squeak, squeak, squeak, squeak, squeak!
And you're like...
No, it's ours!
Thanks for 5 months Patrol here
Silly guys Understood.
Return to your position Hold on.
I don't know where their position is Hide Remi Squeak, squeak, squeak, squeak!
Oh my gosh
Where the heck are we?
I feel like I hear someone walking and I'm scared!
I think I just gotta run for it you guys.
I think I just gotta run for it I don't remember how I got out of here before.
OK, so...
Where's the doors?
I know how...OK, maybe there?
That's such a far away way though
If we...
Oh my goodness.
Thank you for the superchats!
Let's play a game of Kiss, Marry, Kill You must kiss one, kill one and marry one of the three characters Your options are Naked Snake, Ocelot and Eva I would do all three to all three of them I would kiss, marry and kill all three of them.
Does that count?
Marry, marry, marry
In what order?
Well, I would have to probably kiss and marry...
No, I'm not gonna...
I can marry them once they're dead You bring up a valid point Freak Alright guys, let's just go for it No more being scared
Oh, there's a door there Alright Snake, run Open the door!
Snake, that's not a door
Can you not call HQ right now?
Snake, there's a door!
I'm just gonna dodge.
Dodge.
Oh my god.
Snake!
No, no, no!
Snake, Snake.
Snake, don't lay down please.
Oh my gosh Oh no!
They have notified everybody!
Alright, run around.
Run around.
Running around at the speed of sound I'm gonna run into you I'm gonna dodge into you and I'm gonna keep going Oh my gosh Where is the door?
I don't think this will open now, will it?
Oh boy.
Oh here, here, here We made it!
The dogs Just keep running Snake They keep missing.
The dogs!
Where did that dog come from?
Crawl Snake Oh gosh The dog came from nowhere What's the dog doing?
I couldn't even tell you See, we're fine guys
If only that first guy didn't have such good eyes Oh my gosh, wait, I forgot about the sewers
Guys, I think we're gonna have to kill some dogs Oh, how could he have known?
How could he?
How could he have known though?
Dude!
Thanks for the raid!
Hello, hello!
Hi everybody, my name is Mint Phantom!
I'm a ghost made Vtuber!
Hi to you!
We're finishing Metal Gear Solid today so there might be some spoilers Ok, head straight north.
Got it Got it I should probably cure Wait, I don't have anything, do I?
Oh ok, they didn't take anything to heal myself.
That's awesome What's that little beepy sound?
I'm gonna ignore that Raymac, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Casey, thanks for the 5 gifted!
And Dragon, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thank you, thank you I just made a super duper clean...
Oh shoot, I don't have my knife Can I use my fork instead?
No way!
I just made a super duper clean escape from this place Sis, straight!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
Nexie, thanks for the 5 gifted!
I'm bleeding.
Oh, do I need to suture?
And what else do I need to do?
I'm bleeding still?
Stipdick?
There we go, ok.
Ignore that part Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Pegasus, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Oh my gosh, thank you for all the gifted you guys
Ok, I thought I heard...I thought I heard something Why can't you give me my stuff back?
D.Va...
Why couldn't you leave it here?
Like, what is he...oh, he's got his...
He's got his hand on the...Oh my gosh!
Oh my god, it's the B position Alright, north is...oh, which way?
Ignore the beeping
North is...up Six shots Can he do the gun spinning for us?
Wait, can he?
If I go into R1, does he do it?
Snake, dance for me Dance with your gun, Snake
In first person he'll do it?
Let's try it Sorry about the kiss, marry, kill question What do you mean?
Why are you apologizing?
What are you talking about?
It was a great question!
It was my first Super Chat ever.
I wanted to make it MGS3 themed Why are you apologizing?
It was a great question!
Let's see if he does it
Now rotate the analog sticks Spin the right stick
Aim and spin.
I'm aiming Click the right stick.
No I'm doing the right stick!
Up and down?
No?
Then this is the left stick.
This is the right stick Try L1 aiming
Spin!
Huh?
Right stick queen.
Yes, that's what I am doing.
Do I need to...
I think Snake needs to be healed up.
No!
No way He has no confidence right now because he's sick Because he's hungry Wait.
Is there something over there?
No Alright.
Oh, I can't even go that way.
Oh gosh Right stick harder Right stick with all your might Try up, up, down, down, left, right Okay, thank you John Konami is telling me secrets Okay.
I don't actually really like this part
Food Nami It has to be an original camera.
Wait, no really?
Wait, I'm aiming.
Wait, actually L1 doesn't work
Oh, I'm so stupid.
Okay, hold on.
Alright What the?
No!
No?
No, it's not even an original camera Oh gosh, oh gosh I don't know guys, I don't know It's fine though
Can I crawl through here?
Crawl, crawl.
Oh my gosh All I see is darkness Is this just a hiding spot?
Okay, nevermind Item info tells you how to spin I need to know Wait
Aim with... No it doesn't I feel like I'm getting trolled right now Wait, aim with L1 button, play with right analog stick in first person view Aim with... That's what I was doing though Aim with L1 in first person I
needed to not actually be equipping it I should
be doing this.
This is what was throwing it off Okay
I like how they say to play.
It's not like to aim or anything Can I climb up this other side?
I saw a rat.
Oh no, that's not a rat.
I saw a frog Looks tasty
Alright, let's keep going.
Oh wait, let's get my gun out I'm ready to shoot any dogs.
I hope I don't have to, but you know, just in case
They'll be able to sniff me out They're pretty good
There are rats here Wait, which way should I go?
Oh gosh, this is such a maze.
Imagine getting six headshots like that, spinning the gun between each one Wait, how do I get up here?
Oh no, see it's a maze Oh my gosh, okay.
So we have to go up here
I'm ready to kill on sight
I don't think he liked what I...
Wait, where am I hearing him?
I see a little rat.
Are you growling at me?
Oh no, it's definitely...
Where am I hearing him growling from?
Behind the bars?
Hey, shut up!
Shut up!
I won't kill you because you're behind a bar But next time you won't be so lucky, dog
This part is kind of pain.
Oh gosh.
Okay, so it says keep heading north If you can spin a new game plus in front of Ocelot during his boss fight, he'll stop shooting and meet you to do buddy spinning going...
Okay,
just keep going up But it's like a maze, so it's hard to know which way to go
And there's also dogs and people I'm not much of a dog person But I do love animals I don't want to hurt animals
What the?
This goes so far down Wait, where?
Where did you come from?
What?
I don't want to hurt you!
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry I'm sorry!
Guys, don't look Where the heck did he come from?
Where did he come from you guys?
I don't know.
I don't know where he came from.
I'm swimming
Guys, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry I had to do it to him Down
And grab the magazine Where is it?
Wait, I saw it
I saw a magazine There, right there.
Oh, where is that ramen?
Just kidding, I saw ramen noodles Look up, sink and go up
I'm going to eat those?
I guess?
Ramen noodles that were at the bottom of the sewer Delish
Any people?
I don't like this part Wait, what's down there?
I think that's where Kero-tan is or something Wait, did I see something?
There's more!
Gosh, ok I need that Anything?
Oh, nevermind.
Turn around.
I can't see anything It's too dark They were packaged for fine Yeah!
Here boy, here boy.
Oh, where did that dog go?
I hope nothing happened to the orphanage All those orphans are going to be really upset if something happens to them
I'm going to be the villain today.
Screw the orphans
Is it ok for me to be the villain?
Oh, is that another dog?
Oh my gosh, it is And stay there!
Stay there!
Ok, I think I need to go to the other side Oh my gosh, ok, yeah How do I get up there?
Was there a ladder?
Oh, this.
They are right there
Let's try here
I thought... I knew I had seen the stairs Anybody here?
Anybody here?
Ok, that's a gate
Ok, hopefully not Hopefully nobody here Dogs!
I'm getting double dogged I'm really getting double dogged!
Wait!
No!
Oh my God!
Ghost egg!
Shoot!
I'm sorry!
Go, go, go Snake!
Go, go Snake!
Action!
Go!
What's this music?
I did it!
Wait, what's in here?
Oh my God, that was a dog I can't
take this part Oh no!
No, no,
no!
Don't touch me I'm not for you to kill Oh my God, he is living on the edge
I know those footsteps anyway Don't let the BowBows find out.
More will come Oh my God, look how excited he looks to see him
Everybody stand down!
Go away!
This is our time
This little bullet necklace
I've been waiting for this.
Nobody interrupts.
Thank you Wes Oh my God Look how excited he looks.
They both are so excited
Snake!
Stupid Ocelot
There he goes The next what?
What is...Oh my God What is going through his head?
Oh my God Oh God Sorry, hold on a minute Oh gosh, I love this part.
Oh my God, I'm so excited right here No!
My Kamiyoshi is so wholesome Me and my BF, he doesn't know it yet, leaps off a cliff to avoid my love You guys, let's see how clear my river is Besides maybe some...a dog
Let's see how clean my river is Oh my gosh Time to see how many sins you've committed.
I think I've been pretty good
I mean technically Sad, same, sad Sad, so sad
Sad That moment invigorated me for real I'm sad?
Oh gosh I'm sad
He's not bald, he's balding
That's so awesome
Now you will know the sorrow of those whose lives you have ended
Sad boo boo Oh, so awesome!
Oh my gosh, so awesome.
Alright, let's see how clean my river is We got some fish Ok, this is food though.
You can't blame me for that You can't blame me for food Skelly!
I didn't do that.
I didn't kill a Skelly This is all food This is survival Oh, there's a man Our first victim Don't worry about it.
Oh, our second victim too Don't worry about them They had to have it coming, you know Survival Oops, two victims It's still clean though Look, there's only two
And then...
Oh my gosh, I forgot to...I did not get hit by that Bye bye!
Bye bye!
Stop following me!
Obsessed freak
There's the man killed with a fork.
I didn't kill anyone with a fork.
I like the Skellies though Oh my gosh.
That was close Who else did I kill?
So we killed that guy
Halloween is so awesome, right?
Ok, so that's three plus the pain And...
Three plus the pain and the fear Oh,
it's four.
Oh, three plus one boss.
Three plus two bosses The end will not be in here
Yeah, thank you.
Oh my gosh, Halloween is so awesome Fear has the...I know Look at all these fishies Wait, I did not kill this many fish I don't think I killed this many fish This game is gaslighting me now
Another guy?
Wait a second, I didn't kill you Did I?
Did I kill you?
I don't remember killing a fire guy
I had to kill one Ok, five plus two bosses Will we keep it under ten guys?
No,
no, no!
I tricked him!
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no!
This game is lying!
That's so sad But the parrot also didn't die You killed him.
No.
Oh my gosh, who ran that way?
Oh my gosh, that was freaky Guys, I don't think we are keeping it under ten Stay away from me
Stay away from me
Do you guys know that 90's Halloween sound?
That they thought ghosts made
That's how I feel about this area Fury.
Oh my gosh
That's how I feel when the guys go...
Oh, is this it?
Is this the end of the line?
Leave this place How many was that you guys?
How many was that?
Six plus three?
Wait, who is that?
Oh my gosh, there he is.
The sorrow
There he is, there he is Oh my gosh, that scared me No way!
Ok, we already went through it.
Wait, so...
No, I didn't forget.
I forgot that I couldn't touch it I didn't forget about it, but...
Wait, so...
How many was that?
Call over the codec?
Oh yeah, that's a good idea.
These ones are cool.
I like these codec calls
Snake!
You forgot the gimmick.
No, I didn't!
I'm telling you, I didn't, you guys I know I have to take the pill, please Why are you guys always acting like I'm forgetting things?
Snake!
I can take it here though.
Oh, back again?
That's so awesome Yeah, I love it here.
I'm a ghost.
This is where I belong, sorrow This is where I belong Oh my God
I didn't know you could... wait, snake get up.
Snake, can you get up?
I didn't know they'd start coming at me You can drown in here, that's kind of crazy Ok, it's in my backpack.
Wait, no I still have it here, right?
My fake death pill Wait, why won't it let me use it?
Do I actually have to go all the way to the end?
Ok, we'll just run
Use grenades I definitely have those No!
Sick, backflip.
Oh yeah!
Ok, I'm walking.
Don't touch me I love zombie Payne
I don't know why the Payne's name is the most difficult for me to remember
I always want to call him the Fury
When did I kill a helicopter guy?
Not a helicopter guy One of the guys in the thingies
Sorrow, so sorrow
Knocked him out and he crashed.
That shouldn't count though Oh my god.
Wait, we get to see the fear again.
Look at him go Oh my gosh Get it girl
Killing shouldn't count as killing.
It was an indirect thing.
I put him to sleep I put him to sleep, it's not my fault.
He fell asleep and couldn't control his wheel and then...
crashed.
It's not my fault
Where's the guy that ran past us?
That one was fun
Sure.
Indirect murder What's it called?
It's called...
Involuntary manslaughter Maybe Why are you panting like that?
Either.
The bird definitely flew away
I don't think shooting someone...
Shooting someone counts as involuntary But it was a, it was a tranq gun Get away from me you freak
I just put him to sleep, it's not my fault he fell asleep No, no, no.
He fell asleep but he couldn't control his car He should have measures for that Not sure that will hold up in the court of law I think it will
I actually don't mind doing this part because it's just so cool It does hold up in court!
Court!
It holds up in court for real!
Can I use my pill?
No
So what's the order of operations here?
This game always makes me hungry
Touch the corpse, take the pill Okidoki My death pill Wait, it's the death pill The
death pill.
Why can't I use the death pill anyway?
Why can't I use the death pill?
But I want to just die and then come back
Why won't it let me use it?
Wait, I'm so confused
Oh here we go Just kidding, I'm not dead There we go I remember
Yeah, I did forget that part.
I remember that I had to take it I just forgot one thing Hahaha
No Sorrow
Snake, get up
Are you winning son?
Back in the jungle In the jungle, the Russian jungle, the snake sleeps tonight
Wait, where?
Oh there he is.
Bye bye!
Snake How do you do the things you do?
Yeah it was
Up there This is why when...
Yeah actually I'll talk about it after After this
Talk to me!
What about him and the boss?
What was the story between them?
Knew what?
The boss?
No
No Nope.
Still partners, even in death.
Yeah.
I was dead, evil.
Spooky.
It's freaky, alright.
Because it involves ghosts.
That is the sorrow of being left scared.
This game is made for me.
I need my stuff, evil.
Like, now.
Like, this is the perfect time for my moss.
My moss camel.
Can you throw me my stuff here?
I'm gonna get caught, for sure.
They're gonna see my big burly body.
Why is the caution at 99%?
What the hell?
I just got here.
Looking forward to your 3.0 debut.
Thank you, crow!
Is this when Eva can talk about your missing food?
No, because...
Oh
my gosh, snake.
Wait, can I make him throw up?
Let's try.
If he throws up, maybe he'll expel it.
Yeah, time to puke, baby.
You still have the transmitter in your body?
Yeah.
Puke up now.
See?
Okay, let's see.
Hold on.
I love barfing, snake.
Okay.
Is it because of the transmitter that the...
I took it out before, so is it because of the transmitter that I have the caution healer?
I might have to kill people, but now I don't care about my river.
Oh, sorry.
I keep going to the wrong thing.
I'm gonna save real quick, though.
You wanna save?
Hold on a sec.
Yeah, I wanna keep the scene, though.
I love it.
Leave it in now, though.
Yeah, if we have to kill some people, whatever.
We just have to run past them.
It's fine.
Sorry, I gave you the murder pass.
Oh, that's what I wanted to say.
Like, after that codec, right?
And this is some MGS5 spoilers, so...
Wait, I wasn't done talking!
Yeah, which one?
I think he was interested in the mother is a teenage whatever.
But, okay, so...
Some MGSV spoilers, so sorry guys.
I'll wiggle once I'm done talking about them if you wanna go.
Spoilers closing my ears.
Yeah, yeah, close your ears.
So, this is why in 5, when they try to explain everything as being like...
The virus?
Like the parasites or whatever?
Oh, it makes me so mad.
Because Metal Gear has always been a quote-unquote paranormal supernatural...
Not paranormal, but supernatural series.
Right?
And it's so annoying that only until 5.
And that's kind of one of my biggest...
Actually, one of my biggest issues with 5 is that it kind of rewrites this game in that way.
It makes me so angry that it makes everything nanomachines and supernatural stuff.
Like, even in 4, despite so much being nanomachines...
We still have the sorrow appear again.
Slash psychomantic.
Like, you know, it's kind of like, it's still supernatural.
There's still supernatural elements.
Despite how quote-unquote scientific they make it...
Like, there are still these elements that make the game mysterious and fun.
Like, I didn't need an explanation as to why the fear was like the way he was.
Or why the end could have photosynthesis.
I don't care.
They're just cool.
They're just a bunch of freaks.
I didn't think of that.
That just makes me so...
Just Kojima post MGS4.
Everything needed to have a needless explanation.
I know.
That's what...
That was my biggest gripe with V.
Was that it kind of explained...
It just rather...
It filled in quote-unquote plot holes that weren't really...
That people didn't really care about being plot holes.
You know, they weren't actually plot holes.
Like, oh, why did you have to fight Big Boss two times in Metal Gear 1 and Metal Gear 2?
Like, I don't...
Because...
Because he's an 80's action villain.
I don't know.
Like...
And I never even once thought why...
Why is the Cobra Unit like the way they are?
I just thought that they were like a group of...
Supernatural guys.
I mean, not all of them are supernatural.
Like the Fury, he's just an astronaut.
He's just a guy in suit.
Nanomachines and memes.
The DNA of the soul.
Am I right, Mint?
Absolutely.
I don't know.
Playing B-Man with nanomachines or signs.
He's just...
He's just a guy with bees.
And no parasites, no nanomachines, nothing.
You know what?
Actually, it's just so great.
Ocelot is just genuinely the way that he is because of the way that he is.
In this game, he's got no parasites, he's got no nanomachines.
He's just the way that he is...
Because he is.
And I love that for him.
Anyway.
Okay, spoilers over, spoilers over, spoilers over.
I wiggle, I wiggle, I wiggle, I wiggle, I wiggle.
No more spoilers.
Oh, but it really just...
Grinds my gears.
Really grinds my gears, guys.
Uh, okay.
How do I get up here again?
Is there a tree?
I love this music though.
The caution music is so awesome.
Where do I go this way?
Wait.
Oh, I think I go this way.
Just kidding.
I'm a stupid head.
They're gonna see me, so...
Freaks a lot.
I only buy free range GMO free organic super soldiers.
Like Johnny.
Let's get my gun at the ready.
Actually, let's take some...
Let's eat some ration.
Let's eat some ration and then...
Sorry Snake, I know it's bad.
This is horrible.
Is Johnny a super soldier?
What are you talking about?
He's absolutely super.
Shoot guys, I don't remember where to go at all.
Am I going the right way?
I think so.
What's so super about Johnny?
The way his pants just hold it.
I know the guys are gonna see me like immediately if I walk around the corner.
You know what I mean?
I see two of them!
Anyone up here?
No, no, no Snake.
I need you to crawl.
What the hell?
How?
Why am I holding it like this?
How the hell am I supposed to shoot this?
Snake?
Snake.
Oh my gosh, thank you guys for the super chat!
Gotta aim it.
Oh, he's gone.
Joy, thank you so much!
Oh my gosh, how?
L1 is not working you guys.
Just letting you know.
Wait, how do I get around here?
Oh, here we go.
What the?
Wait, are you stupid?
I think he's dumb.
Oh my gosh, I think he's really stupid.
There we go.
Is he coming?
Sorry, sorry Ocelot unit.
I shot you in the head!
How did you survive?
Maybe you guys are the super soldiers.
Sorry guy.
You okay?
I don't know why it will not let me aim in first person while I'm laying down with this gun.
Kind of awful.
Like, how do I do it?
Just aim real good.
I'm trying!
Maybe if I...
Okay.
Let's just do it like this.
He doesn't see me.
Oh, sorry for your...
Sorry for your arm.
There we go.
Oh, I see another guy.
That's where I need to go, isn't it?
Like right there.
Honestly, I could just...
Okay.
I don't know how to aim with this thing.
And to the right a little.
What do you mean, huh?
Just run!
Nobody saw me.
I'm gonna run.
I'm reloading.
And the alert is gone.
Maybe I made it.
Where's my fork?
He's hiding in the trees!
I'm...
What are you doing over there?
What's your arm doing?
I'm in the jungles of Russia.
Oh, shoot.
That's not what I meant to do.
Flush him out!
Oh, gosh.
Go, snake, go.
That.
Yeah, he was jorking it in the Russian jungles.
And by it, I mean my rations.
Ramen.
Radio.
Dead body.
Still warm.
Why are you caressing it like that?
Hot lady incoming!
I'm Tatiana.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
I could use my clothes.
I could use a lot of things.
Save, yes.
New character?
Chat needs a towel.
Yeah, Eva, I could use a new eye, okay?
But, like...
It makes me cool.
Oh, boy.
Oh, he's gonna be chowing down.
Oh, god.
He really just knows how to...
How to make a lady just...really...
Holy golly.
Hey, stop blocking the goods.
Not for dinner.
In my training, we always got the good stuff.
French, Italian.
That kind of thing.
The least you could do is call me Cynthia.
I don't get that.
Mata Hari.
Stop interrupting his meal.
Holy moly.
This man has been eating raw fish this whole time.
Stop it.
No,
I can't see.
My depth perception.
Ow, that hurts, Eva.
It's still fresh.
It happened, like, today.
Eva, it happened, like...
It's still fresh, Eva.
He's got someone else on the mind, Eva.
Eva, you...
You are too late, girly.
He's got the mission, you guys.
It's not time yet.
What's with the sexy music?
That's a car.
What is happening?
Like this?
Pretty good at that.
Yeah, everybody tells me that.
Hold steady.
I'm not done yet.
There.
A transmitter.
Is that how they do it in the KGB?
Sometimes.
Would you rather I did it American style?
How'd you know there was a transmitter lodged there?
That's some female intuition you've got.
Look how excited he is.
I've watched that scene, like, a million times.
What are you gonna do?
Kiss me every time.
Wait, do you have that female intuition?
I think so.
With just this much you could blow up the Shagohat and the lab along with it.
Oh, I have an update.
I finished the book.
I finished the Sweet Berries book finally.
Oh my god.
Kojimbo does it again.
Cute.
I'm gonna shape it into something else.
I'll just squash it.
No response.
Just shoves it in his back pocket.
The Shagohat's booster unit uses liquid fuel.
The fuel tanks are in the main wing of the weapons lab in the hangar housing the Shagohat itself.
So I should blow up the tanks?
That's the basic idea.
It should be enough to blow up the entire hangar.
There are four fuel tanks.
In order to destroy the hangar, you'll have to set explosives on each of those tanks.
All four of them?
It should be no sweat for you.
Besides, the scientists had the day off today.
So the hangar is completely deserted.
Not quite.
They've still got guards posted there.
So what do I do after I set the C3?
The bombs run off the timer.
I wish it was just the guards.
Once the timer has been set, the countdown will begin.
When the timer reaches zero, the bombs will all go off at once.
How long do I have?
20 minutes.
Once the phase 2 trials are finished, I wouldn't be surprised if they kill all the scientists to prevent them from talking.
So you've got to act fast.
I'll take care of it.
Oh boy.
Eva, did you get the data on the Shagohod from Sokolov?
Yeah, that's the mission I was given.
By Khrushchev?
America doesn't have any use for it, does it?
But I haven't forgotten my other mission either.
What's that?
Helping you out.
Oh my god.
She's so beautiful.
Snake has zero interest in her.
He's just so like...
Every time.
Yeah.
He has priorities.
Yeah, truly.
I can't wait to see Eva in Delta though.
She is so beautiful.
So much better than the Apache slot.
I'm so happy.
I mean, I can't wait to see everybody though.
Oh gosh.
I...
Eva.
What?
It's just too late, girl.
You just don't have that freak in you.
You don't match his freak.
The real you.
What's your name?
Tatiana.
No.
Your real name.
What's wrong with Tanya?
Okay, Tanya.
Don't let anyone see you.
Oh, this?
It's a button camera.
Oh my god.
What did you do that for?
Insurance.
To make sure you don't double cross me.
Okay.
I would never do that.
And you better not do the same.
What?
It's okay.
The wind will dry her.
Oh man.
That line actually made me tear up a little bit.
Sorry.
During these cutscenes, I'm just always holding down R1.
Okay.
Let's grab any goodies she left in here for me.
Warm.
Disinfect.
Let's see.
All the bites.
The bites are so cute.
Wait, what's the original in here?
Oh, the original camera angle is...
You get to see the bites.
Look how cute they are!
Grab some...
Oh boy, they're giving me a lot of stuff.
Guys, I don't remember at all the strat for Vulcan.
So if you guys don't mind...
Helping a girl out when it comes to time.
Wait, where's my knife?
You think Eva would ask him to form the beast with two backs?
What is the beast with two backs?
Just finished replaying MGS4, that line hit hard.
I know!
What's the beast with...
Two backs?
No way!
It's two people boinking.
Is that what it's called?
Wait, that's another name.
It's Shakespeare's term.
No way!
Seriously?
I've never heard of that before.
We need that.
We need...
Let's get the book.
Fine.
I want to keep the rotten bat because I want them to get sick.
Shakespeare had some freaky euphemisms.
The beast with two backs.
Wait, I forgot my knife.
Wow.
The beast with two backs.
Beast with two backs.
I like how it stops glowing.
There was some food here.
Yeah, let's grab some food while we're here as well.
Some little froggies.
Come here.
Beast with two backs.
Beast with three backs.
Let's not get ahead of ourselves now.
Rat.
Take you.
Wait, do I not have enough room maybe?
Snake.
Just, snake.
I've never seen you use a death pill for bosses.
You get a free hit on all the bosses if you use one.
Because I don't need to play dead.
I'm just too good.
I'm just that good where I don't need to play dead at all.
Nice.
Oh wait, how much food do we have anyway?
You're already dead.
That too.
Oh, I don't have a lot of food at all.
Let's stock up.
We got the box!
Exciting times.
Beast with two backs.
I wonder what that tastes like.
Snake probably.
He would ask.
He would wonder.
You know those memes that's like knows what... knows what boinking is, boinks.
Does not know what the boinking is, doesn't boink.
I feel like Snake does not know but still boinks.
Oh, I forgot to say.
Oh my gosh.
I finished the book.
Update on the book time before we head on inside.
Okay, so I finished the book.
Thank god because I...
I hated this book.
So for those who don't know, I was reading a sequel to the Minotaur Milking Farm and it was about a lady and her mothman buddy.
And it was just so... Oh my gosh.
I hated the girl.
I hated the guy.
I hated the writing.
Everything about it was just...
I would like fall asleep and then I would have to remember and I would like finish the book in my sleep, right?
So I didn't know where I left off.
But I would have to find where I left off.
And let me tell you, the book repeats lines so often that I was physically groaning.
I was just like, oh my god, I cannot hear her say this line one more time.
It was so bad.
Okay, let me tell you.
The first line was she would always say, here for a good time, not a long time.
And she would be trying not to fall in love with this mothman but she would always be like, here for a good time, not a long time.
Just don't fall in love with him.
And I'm like, oh god, shut up!
And then always, the second thing she would always talk about is how adorable his little chirps and clicks are.
And that just drove, she would be like, he's just so adorable when he started doing his little chirps.
Or every time I said something and he would chirp and it was just the most adorkable thing.
God, I wanted to strangle the main lady.
I seriously, oh my god, I was losing my mind because she would say it every two sentences.
It was so annoying.
And then, the other thing that she would say is, she would talk about his like, his neck fluff.
Every two seconds she would be like, I buried my head into his fluffy neck fluff.
Oh, I stroked his neck fluff.
I wondered about the smell of his neck fluff.
Shut up!
Oh my god, I was losing my mind because it was so awful.
And then, oh my god.
Basically, I was just so ready to be done with the book.
And then, okay, let me tell you why I also just hate these characters.
First of all, the guy is just stupid.
He's just, he doesn't communicate well and that annoys me.
But then second, the girl is kind of awful.
So, in this world, in this world, there are, there are, there are creatures with innies, which is not a belly button.
It's their, it's their, it's their, you know, other appendages.
And then there's ones with outies.
If they are outies, they must wear pants.
But if they're innies, they don't have to wear pants.
But then there's like this whole side plot about her having to appeal to the werewolf people because one of them is going to become mayor.
And they, he doesn't want people, or animal people to not wear pants.
He wants everyone to wear pants and clothes and stuff.
And she's just like, but the mothman guy, he doesn't wear pants.
And she's just like, we need to get you some pants.
And he's like, I don't like pants.
And she's like, no, no, no, we're getting you pants.
And I'm like, what, why don't you accept him?
I thought it was going to turn into like, because she was, the whole time she was like supporting this guy.
And I thought it was going to turn into like a, oh, you know what?
I'm going to stand up against the guy and say, you know what?
Against the mayor and say, you know what?
My mothman, he doesn't need to wear pants.
And instead, no, she just gives it, she's just like, she's just like, oh no, we're getting you pants.
Don't you want to be accepted by everyone else in the town?
You have to wear pants.
And he's like, oh, I don't really like the feel of pants.
All clothes are kind of restricting for me because I'm a mothman and nothing fits.
And she's like, no, we're getting you pants.
And I'm like, what?
I thought she was going to like, I thought she was going to be on his side.
And instead she's just like, no, you need to conform to the city.
You need to, if you're going to live here with me, you need to, you need to be like everybody else and you need to blend in.
Mothman oppression.
I know!
I was so, I was so, I was like, wait, what?
But he says he doesn't like them.
It's so mean.
You will wear pants, you will eat slop, you will boycott.
This is any erasure.
He deserves better.
It was making me actually so mad because I was like, this guy doesn't like wearing pants.
And she was so adamant.
Like every, after, like the mayor or the future mayor, I guess, she was so insistent that he was going to become mayor.
The guy wasn't even mayor yet.
She was just like, he came to where she worked one day and saw that he wasn't wearing pants and like glared at him.
And then, sorry, your Mothman smite was poorly written.
But then, literally right afterwards, she like looks at the Mothman guy and she's like all embarrassed.
She's like, we need to get you pants, like right now.
And I'm like, what?
Banning pants, is this strike witches now?
Yes!
I was so angry.
Yeah, she's toxic.
She was very toxic.
I was angry for him, even though I didn't like him.
I didn't like her more.
I was like, this lady sucks.
So you don't recommend the book?
No.
The first book was good.
This one was so bad.
I was so angry.
And then she was just like, if you don't wear pants, anyone can touch you down there.
And, you know, you're only for me.
And he's just like, no, because it's like a vacuum or something.
He's like...
He's like, I just vacuum seal it shut.
And guess what, guys?
She became boneless!
At one point she was like, I was lying on my bed boneless.
This Mothman lore is gone.
There's so many twists and turns.
She said that she became boneless!
Oh, gosh.
I have... I think I have like...
I feel like I need like a little bit of therapy from the imagery in this book in particular.
Oh, it was just... A lot of it was just really...
Oh, gosh.
A minty-made ghost.
Wonder what that tastes like.
A snake in midstream.
She became a chicken wing.
Real.
Yeah.
Looks like this are curling me.
Me too.
That's why I listen to them.
I read them so you don't have to and then I report them back.
You're welcome.
I didn't even tell you some of the worst parts about it.
And honestly, I don't want to repeat them.
I don't want to repeat them.
We now know an impressive amount of this book series now.
We could use this knowledge for a great conversation starter at parties.
Both men deserve better.
You could!
How is she going to wear pants if she is boneless?
I know!
Oh, gosh.
Mint please, we need more.
I don't want to talk about it.
Is there a sequel?
Apparently there is a third book.
At the very end they gave...
Okay, so it was like they had an epilogue chapter that was like I guess the first...
Or like the beginning of a third book.
This is weird.
I was just lying in bed last night trying to fall asleep.
And they finished the book.
Or they finished this like little... It was about like a werewolf and then...
He's like... There's like a place for interspecies couples...
Where if they can't have a kid but want a kid, they instead hire a werewolf to...
To boink the other werewolf so that they can have a kid.
But...
I'm like, I don't... Isn't that kind of...
It's like actual NTR, right?
But it ends... Oh gosh.
When I heard this I was like, no, no, I can't do this.
No.
It said...
Join us...
Join us on this...
16 book part series.
Ah!
16 books!
I can't, no.
No, I tap out.
I tap out, you guys.
I can't do it.
16!
I don't know if they are all part of the same city or whatever.
I guess so.
The first one is Minotaur.
The second one is Mothman.
The third one is Werewolf.
The world is our oyster.
We can only go up from here.
I don't know.
Also, at one point...
They were like...
I'm confused because...
The Mothman was a scientist and he was studying hummingbirds.
Also, they went to an ice cream place and one had aphids in it.
She was like, I don't know what Mothman eat.
Do you want aphids?
He was like, aphids?
Are you crazy?
She was like, I don't know.
But...
A Mothman is an insect.
He was looking after hummingbirds and butterflies.
Are there butterfly people?
Do it for the content.
Oh gosh.
Are there butterfly people?
What do you mean VOD watchers skip 30 minutes ahead?
This is content!
Are there butterfly people?
Why is he a Mothman but there is not a butterfly man or butterfly woman?
Why is there...
Are there also hummingbird people?
Where does it end?
I'm confused.
Also, I couldn't get it out of my head because he would like, talk to her while they were doing sexy time.
He would talk to her but his little moth tongue was like, out on the floor.
And the whole time I'm just thinking of him being like, oh yeah, you're so beautiful.
What did I tune into?
Sorry.
I'm giving a final update to the book I've been reading.
So guys, I finished the 15th book.
Bigfoot finished Deli.
Yeah, so this is Monster Musume for normies.
It's extremely anime coded but yeah, basically.
Wasn't he voiced?
Yeah, but of course the... Oh my gosh, here's the kicker guys.
Here's the final... Here is the final piece of this cake.
This cake that... I don't even... The pie.
You know what the narrator's name is?
At the very end I had to hear her say it and I was like, oh my god.
The narrator, the lady who was voicing the audio book, her name is Eva!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, cell type, you were so close.
Eva Tatiana, her name was Eva!
Oh my gosh, full circle reel.
Anyway, alright.
Sorry, I just had to talk about that for a little bit.
Okie dokie.
Oh gosh.
Wait, can I put on... What outfit can I wear here?
I can't wear Rykov anymore, right?
But I can wear the scientist, right?
It was all one big Metal Gear reference.
Don't you have the sorrow camel?
I don't think I got that, did I?
Oh I did!
The sorrow camel uniform!
Wait, what's the special thing about this one?
Spooky.
Silence footsteps.
Oh that's right, that's right.
Codec with it.
Yeah, yeah, we'll see.
Oh, hold on.
Not a bad idea.
We started a good term.
Spiky flames.
Ok, no pressure.
No pressure.
Is it SIGINT?
Oh wait, yeah SIGINT tells me about Camel.
SIGINT.
Yeah.
See?
AI is not gonna take our jobs.
We need the humans.
Snake talking about someone's social problems is insane.
Snake!
Oh I thought he meant like his personality.
Because Snake's personality is...
Aww.
Yeah, it doesn't matter.
You can hack the system.
Anybody can hack the system.
Let's talk to Zero real quick.
Guys, I don't remember the strat for Vulcan.
I need your help.
Hacking into the gate.
No!
Ok
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
You'll remember when you fight him.
I don't think I will.
We'll see though.
I remember more of the Shagglehug fight than the fight with him.
Are you gonna tell me about the Camel?
Oh there we go.
There we go, there we go.
The sorrow.
Hehehe
It did!
Yeah.
What?
Alrighty.
We'll save once we...
Oh no, no, no.
I didn't mean to...
Oh, I'm not wearing any face paint.
You're right.
Thank you, second.
I'm not wearing any face paint.
Camouflage.
Let's see.
Oh, Splitter my favorite.
Wait, zombie?
Zombie with the sorrow?
But Splitter is my favorite.
Ok.
Zombie?
Ok, we'll go with zombie.
Look how cool!
Oh my gosh.
Zombie for Halloween.
Alright.
Let's go.
Nice.
I don't wanna be back here.
Oh, Eva!
Yeah, I forgot to call Eva.
Gotta call her.
Hold on.
Oh, goodness.
Hurry up, snake.
Hurry up and get out.
Meow.
Snake, hide!
Hide, snake!
Oh my gosh.
What if they park on top of that?
We never... If we had waited any longer...
Oh my gosh!
Oh my
gosh!
We would have been in bad trouble.
Who could have known?
Alrighty.
So if I can't... Can I be a scientist here?
I can though.
Inside I need the janitor's outfit.
But, can I be a scientist here?
I can't remember.
Yeah, I can, right?
Ok, let's call Eva real quick.
You can get into the hangar through the door located at the entrance to the main wing on the second floor of the east wing.
Hurry!
But Eva, did you take my food?
Eva, didn't you take a picture of me when I was about to leave the waterfall cave?
No, that.
That's a button-shaped hidden camera developed by the KGB.
Wow.
I use it to take pictures of the fortress and Shagahan.
That's so Detective Conan.
No.
Why did you take a picture of me?
Because I wanted a picture of you.
Can I have it, Eva?
Eva, can I get that picture?
Can you make a copy for me?
Please, Eva.
My Rykov disguise.
Ok.
With a box?
Perhaps?
Ok, ok.
Let's equip my box.
Where is box C that I just got?
Box, box...
Box B.
Oh, C, box B.
Splitter, splitter.
It works.
It's pretty crazy.
Alright.
Splitter.
Oh, that's a doubt.
And any people...is it this?
Wait, what's the car that I can go into?
For...
What kind of truck is it?
It's not this one, obviously.
Is it...that one over there?
No, not that...oh, wait.
Wait, can I get in here?
Near the walkway.
Where's the walkway?
I like how it says it silences my footsteps, but it doesn't feel like it, you know what I mean?
It scares me still.
Oh my gosh, there's two guys there.
Wait, this is...
This is a moment of...
What's wrong?
This is a what's wrong loop.
Oh no, don't get him.
No wait, why did you crouch?
Shit.
What the?
How did you...
This is HQ.
Patrol here.
Where did that other guy go?
He disappeared.
Oh shoot.
I'm gonna go into a box.
I didn't even think I had that equipped.
That's why I did it with...
Oh...
You wanna save?
Hold on a sec.
Whoopsie-poopsie.
Permanent tranquilizer.
I didn't even notice.
I'm gonna do a new file.
Did you enjoy the killing?
No!
What's wrong?
Denied.
Oh my gosh, I almost...Oh my gosh!
Saving after you killed a dude.
Well I forgot to save before I killed him.
Oh I've seen North by Northwest.
I like this one actually.
It's a...not Hitchcock is it?
Maybe it is Hitchcock.
Yes it is Hitchcock.
Oh I thought so.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Rebecca.
I don't know that one.
She saw the dead in that river and wanted to send more people there.
You wanna know what's wrong but instead got a what's wrong with you.
I wonder if that's also Kojima's first, you know.
I might wanna just restart this section, I'm not gonna lie.
I'm not in your way.
Don't even act like I am.
Don't even act like I'm...don't, don't.
What are you doing here?
Go away!
Oh my god.
Just a vaccine.
Holy cow, I thought...I thought he was gonna go like...
You know, I thought he was gonna do his little thing.
He didn't though.
We...gamed for real.
Are they gonna look around?
There's no one else right?
Can I go up through there?
Wait, which is the place I need to go to?
Ma...
Like, I know how I got there before.
Can I go up through that door up there though?
I wish I could shoot from my box.
This door is still locked.
Okay, thank you.
We'll run once this guy turns around.
Oh my gosh, I just saw the guy up there.
Holy moly, he would have seen me.
He would have spotted me probably.
I don't know where those other guys went, so I'm a little nervous to get out of my box.
Okay, first...Oh my gosh.
There they are.
Take out this guy first.
If I can.
Dang it.
Oh, don't move.
Wait, is he in a glass?
No, he's outside.
Oh my gosh, control.
Nice.
There's a guy there.
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no.
HQ.
Oh, what are you doing?
Are you just chilling?
Okay, good night.
Oh no!
Wait a second.
Return to your positions, sirs.
He's taking a nap.
They're leaving?
Hold on, I'm going to box.
This is why we box, everybody.
This is why we box.
Oh my gosh, he's going to notice this guy too.
What if I just go...
Oh, he didn't notice him.
They're dumb.
They're so stupid.
Let's go.
Hi, run.
So, here...
Yeah.
Northeast.
Move who?
Who are we telling to move?
Who are we calling a bastard?
Move!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, stop bullying him!
Stop bullying him!
They're going.
I think.
It's this building.
The door is like right...Oh gosh.
How the hell am I supposed to get to here?
Faster.
Oh, bastard.
Sorry.
Move.
What are they doing?
I think they're doing...
What's that exercise where you run back and forth?
Why are they crawling?
Why are they running like this?
You lousy!
Um...
There's like a bunch of guys here, you guys.
Can I even get in through here?
You lousy!
Maybe if I use like a grenade or something.
Like a...
You lousy!
I can't see anything.
Oh gosh.
This camera angle is so awful.
You lousy!
Run.
I made it.
Anybody?
Ok, there's a door.
There's a guy right there.
That I can see.
You lousy!
OG camera my belo...Oh there's a guy right there too!
Oh my gosh.
OG camera saved me.
I wouldn't have seen him.
Look, he's looking right at me too.
You lousy!
Where is he?
I think I can get him.
Where are they?
There's a guy.
He's coming this way.
You lousy!
Don't notice me.
Don't.
There we go.
My girl.
You lousy!
I know there's...
Oh I thought that was a guy.
Oh my gosh.
I know there's stuff in there, but it's ok.
Now here...
I can be a scientist, right?
Alright.
Yes.
Thank you.
What if I want to be...
The zombie scientist, huh?
Alright, here we go.
All scientists are off-duty though.
Let's see.
I can save.
They might not know that.
They might forget.
I'm gonna save to make sure.
Yay!
They might forget.
And if there's no scientist, even better for me.
Zombies are not approved personnel.
Snope.
The blob.
That's what they call me at the club.
I know.
It's just like my video game.
Alright.
If I die here because I'm a scientist...
Scientists have rights!
There are scientists in there.
Dang it.
How do I get in there again?
Do I go around the other way?
I'm also a scientist.
I would like to go down the science stairs as a scientist.
My hypothesis is...
The steps are very narrow.
If he was upstairs, I would have been able to CQC him and take him to the door.
But unfortunately, we do not have that option.
So let's try...
Door number two!
I am a scientist.
I'm doing my science things.
Sneaking suit!
It's the MGS3 sneaking suit!
It looks so good!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, where do I get the other one?
I can't remember.
I love the MGS3 sneaking suit.
Because it looks so much like the boss.
The latest battle uniform developed by the Soviet Union cuts all damage in half and reduces...
What button is that?
Reduces...
Circle?
Stamina consumption!
Oh wait, R2.
There we go.
Yay!
Actually,
where do I get the janitor outfit?
Let's see.
It reduces...
Do people come in here?
No.
This is the scientist's room.
This is only for me.
I thought I just heard someone walking.
Janitor!
I'm a scientist trying to rob everybody in the office.
Do not mind me.
What is this?
Wow.
Is that...
Is that one of the enders?
Did someone just come in?
He's coming this way!
Stop, stop, stop.
I'm trying to do science.
Suppressor for the AR.
Is that what I got?
I saw that I got a suppressor.
I'll be honest, I was half paying attention.
There we go!
Our janitor uniform.
Perfect.
How is he just so handsome in everything he wears?
How are you actually a perfect being?
We got a second perfect being right there baby.
Now to maneuver through the hallway of lockers.
I think I got all of them.
I think so.
We're ready.
Sneaky, sneaky, sneaky...
Snake don't go in there yet.
I got to change.
Yeah!
That guy is nuts.
Blow it up.
I don't want to think about it yet.
We have one thing at a time Major.
Yeah.
Without getting caught.
A key.
Good man.
Liquid?
I will go down with this ship.
Okay.
Not looking forward to Voldemort.
I got to do this part right first though.
One moment.
Wait, hold on.
Let me save.
Yeah!
We just have a little bit left to go though.
As long as I'm good at the game.
You'll be fine.
You're going to crush Vulcan.
Easy, easy.
I don't know.
I feel like I... I don't think I struggled...
I don't remember struggling with him as much as I did with...
Such as like the Fury, but I remember the Shagohad gave me some issues.
Snake hasn't seen anything.
Not going to skin if you want to do lethal.
We'll do lethal.
I'm not aiming for any specific ranks or anything though.
I'm just having fun.
Oh!
A date?
Did you get Vulcan's camo is crazy powerful for the bike escape?
Really?
I think the bike escape is not so bad though.
Hi.
What's the 7th fleet?
Does that mean he's dead?
Is he gone?
What does that mean?
It's the one after 6.
Maintenance here.
Nobody noticed me.
With my maintenance uniform.
I know there's a guy up here.
Yeah, I remember him.
These guys have eagle eyes though.
These guys are kind of crazy.
Nice butt.
The definition.
It's really...
It's really prominent, isn't it?
Alrighty, let's find...
I remember... Let's see.
Can these guys see me?
Will they recognize me?
I can't remember.
We'll find out right now.
I know those guys can.
So there's one right here.
There's one down there, I believe.
If I... Oh, I was going to take him out.
There's one right here, yeah.
Where's my C3?
Would it be under the other one?
Under weapon?
C3...
And... Dang it.
Magazine.
No, not magazine.
Oh my gosh, I was thinking of the book.
Like an actual magazine, you know?
Eat the C3.
Oh here we go.
Book.
I think this might be helpful for some of the guards.
Yeah.
C3.
OK.
Press...
Square.
Can I put it here?
Or do I have to put it...
Oh gosh.
Get up.
I don't remember where I have to put it.
Like here?
Does that work?
How many do I have?
Three.
That works.
Right?
That one guy.
He'll be fine.
He'll be OK.
I'm looking.
I'm doing... not C3 things.
Yeah.
Eva.
Yippee.
Good.
Yeah.
OK.
Totally not planting...
C3.
Not at all.
Never done that in my life.
I
don't want this guy to see me.
Don't see me.
Sir?
OK.
C3.
Oh shoot.
What?
Ah!
I'm telling you they have eagle eyes!
Oh my gosh!
No!
We were so close.
Eagle eyes!
I'm telling you that's some crazy picture.
I know!
That's what I mean!
OK.
Now I have to put all my stuff back.
I can't let go of you.
Come.
C3.
Look.
This is what it looks like.
I have not seen that happen before.
That was really funny.
I'm glad that I could fulfill that...
That new experience for you.
Let's get rid of this guy because I'm afraid of him being able to...
Also eagle eye me and all.
I'm going to...
I'm going to get this guy.
Oh wait.
I should be OK.
Oh whoops.
No, no, no.
That's not...
Nashi!
Thanks for the 10 gifts!
Thank you so much!
Oh my gosh, I keep pressing X.
Let's just... What's good?
Olive Drab is really good.
Is that the best?
It's the best.
My Olive Drab.
And of course Splitter.
My favorite.
OK.
Now, let's take out this guy.
By take out I mean put him to sleep.
Good night little baby.
OK.
Fast, fast, fast, fast.
OK, I have to be really fast because this guy is going to notice me, isn't he?
Shoot!
I thought he was going to be...
OK, OK, OK.
Oh gosh.
Look at the way Naked Snake just stands there.
Look at that stance.
He didn't notice.
Good night little baby.
Nobody noticed.
Good.
Notice?
No, I don't think so.
OK, I'm going to skip you Eva.
Sorry.
Don't have time.
Yeah, he's overworked.
Always working so hard.
It's really difficult being a guy here.
You know?
It's really difficult being...
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Run away!
OK.
Snake, I need you to go a little faster up this hill, OK?
Thank you.
Alright, eagle eyes over here.
Oh no, no, no, no.
Where is our little eagle eyed pal?
There he is.
I'm going to take you out.
I really honestly want to just kill him, but...
I won't do that.
I won't do that to you.
Don't worry.
I'll make you go out nice and easy.
Use the trank.
Yeah, unfortunately I'm going to tranquilize them instead of killing them.
Can I even get this guy from down here?
Oh gosh.
Wait, where is he?
Stop moving!
I've got my cigarette spray.
I'm ready for a day, so I gotta run.
OK.
Still at the 3 Z's.
The fact that you can hear the bombs is kind of diabolical.
Nobody notice the ominous beeping sound.
Nobody notice, OK?
Good, good.
Nobody notice the ominous beeping.
Nobody notice the ominous beeping sound.
OK, we have that guy put to sleep.
We are good to go.
Here we go.
You need to change the battery in your fire alarm.
Oh, that's not a very long timer, Snake.
Oh my gosh.
Screw this heart.
Yeah, he's something else.
This guy is just like, sorry Eva and your feelings.
Symbolism.
This is so awesome.
Slam!
Nice.
OK, let's go.
Major, I finished planting the C3.
I'm on my way out now.
Yes.
I hope so.
I love this man.
Me too.
He's such a goofy guy.
Oh no!
Eva!
Buzz!
Look at him.
He's like, I'll fight you.
In my maintenance uniform.
I'm the janitor!
Fancy kicking.
I should have changed before we did this.
I'm the janitor!
It's time to take out the trash.
That's a lot.
He wouldn't.
Yes please.
Please.
I'm the janitor.
Garbage day.
Alright, 13 minutes guys.
Before this place explodes.
And then it's going to be less than that because Volgin is going to talk his whole mouth off.
Look at that.
The snake is too cool looking.
She doesn't have it, does she?
The Philosopher's Legacy!
The Philosopher's Legacy.
I know.
You're stressing me out, Sorrow.
You are stressing me out.
The smell.
The gasoline.
It was gasoline.
Motorcycle gasoline.
She reeked of it.
Yeah, I believe that.
Aw, lovely.
Oh gosh.
Yeah.
Stinky.
I think he liked her.
Aw, headbutt.
No!
She's very fine.
At least she was lovely and stinky.
Obedient.
Oh my gosh.
I like how they don't subtitle that.
The kiss of death.
Kiss of death!
Dang it.
Eva, you had one job.
Remember when I said that in a goofy detective drama?
You dirty whore.
I've had enough kisses from you.
I can't get over that.
Sokolov wasn't man enough to have a lover like that.
Just like the KGB to send something so beautiful, yet so deadly.
What is the Philosopher's Legacy?
He explained it!
He explained it during the Torture Snake.
Weren't you paying attention while he was like...
while you were on the brink of death?
Come on!
Hey Lord Dom!
He was too busy suffering.
Oh come on.
Oh.
Research.
Money,
money baby.
Real footage.
Oh.
Who the hell is that guy?
His face!
He just looked like a balloon.
Skull face real.
Actually though, right?
My father was one of the men in charge of managing the Philosopher's Legacy.
In the confusion that ensued after the war ended, he devised a series of ingenious plots to ensure that the Soviet Union would have total control over the legacy.
The money was divided up and laundered through banks all over the world.
Switzerland, Australia, and Hong Kong.
This microfilm contains a record of all those transactions.
Is that Vulcan's dad or Vulcan?
He looks like such a chad.
After my father's death, I learned of this secret and obtained the microfilm.
This is his dad.
Ok.
With this money and the support of Brezhnev and his allies, I built this fortress of Groznygrad and Grannon's research facility.
But that worthless fool Grannon failed to produce results.
I was forced to turn to Khrushchev's dog Sokolov and his invention, the Shagohog.
Khrushchev was just...he wasn't ready.
He was working on it.
My position in GRU made it too troublesome to attack Sokolov's facility directly.
But the spy network established by the secret pact still existed.
I used it to contact the boss and suggested that she defect.
The boss was conniving enough to see things my way.
The world was once one, but the conflict between the philosophers has torn it in two.
We will use the legacy to heal that rift and make the world whole again.
To do this we need strength.
An unstoppable trump card with enough power to bring order to the world.
The skeleton face behind them is so scary.
That trump card was to be the Shagohog and the Cobra unit.
Is that the sorrow?
You guys see it?
Creepy.
I wonder what these pictures will look like in Delta.
Like if they'll have the Shagohog or what.
Ooh, trust in her.
Okay.
She's like, bitch!
Give me the legacy!
I like just listening to her squeaky clothes.
It's kind of like... it's like an ASMR.
She saw right through me.
Yeah, do that.
Leave everything to me.
Okay, don't talk too loud boss.
Okay, I think he can still hear.
SpongeBob, that is Pearl.
That is Pearl.
Oh my gosh, it's so weird.
Fight like a warrior, Volgin.
Oh gosh, I'm nervous.
Sorry for the look on his face.
Ocelot, you little freak.
He said this like 3 times now.
Volgin is like, stop with your clown shows.
What do you mean judo?
It's CQC.
I've been waiting for this moment.
Times 3.
Volgin standing man emoji in the background.
Hurry up!
Oh boy.
The socks are off.
Gosh.
Silence!
Look at his mannerisms, this theater kid.
Now that I've told you everything you need to know to win the game, time to go.
Oh.
Shut up Nano, I don't want to hear this.
Every hotel got the Ocelot chair.
We only got 7 minutes you guys.
I think we are in trouble.
Kept you waiting, huh?
Guys, I'm nervous.
Ah!
I'm nervous, I don't remember the strategy.
Oh gosh, ok.
We'll just figure it out as we go.
What is the hotel chair?
I've seen that before.
What's the hotel chair?
Win.
Oh my god, my ears though, please.
The chair you sit in while watching your wife get...
Ok, thank you Sorrow.
Snake!
The music.
Ah!
Nice catch.
He says so much in so little words.
He says everything in just actions.
Alright, time to switch clothes.
I'm done being a janitor.
Start.
Let's see, ok.
Snaking suit.
Let's see.
Let's call people.
Where did he put his knife?
He has a little sheath on his chest.
Zero, help me please.
Oh ok, I was just going to run into them.
Ok.
CQC!
Yeah, I know.
Ok.
What about Sigint, what do you have to say?
CQC, CQC.
So don't say CQC.
Ok!
I'll just...
Bullets aren't magnetic.
Electromagnetic fields wouldn't do anything to...
Just...
It's...
It's Metal Gear, ok.
Just let it happen.
Hold on, I also want to get...
Maybe a big gun.
In my arsenal.
Oh wait!
Or should I try and do the suppressor?
But...
CQC will do his stamina, not his...
His actual health, right?
CQC will stamina drain him.
Yeah, ok.
So maybe we'll have enough bullets.
I won't need it.
After this, I don't really need it.
I don't really need it.
Even probably for one more battle.
If I had to do one more battle, we don't know yet.
If I had to fight anybody else...
I mean, we kind of know that we have to fight the boss.
But, if I...
Ok.
Alright.
Alright, cool.
Let me take off my suppressor.
Well, I don't really need it anyway.
After this, anyway.
But, whatever, whatever, whatever.
Oh yeah, that's right.
He kills the animals and stuff.
Can I fight you?
Can I hit you?
I don't know.
Sorry guys, this might take a couple tries.
We'll see how long it takes me, really.
I'm trying to get to his back.
He turned around so fast.
I'm trying to get to his back, but he turned around.
Try the slam.
Oh
my...
Dude, no way.
Slamming, slamming, slamming, slamming, slam.
Ouchie, ouchie.
Oh wait, can I...
No, this is going to explode my bullets.
Can I shoot him?
No, I wonder.
Oh my gosh.
Well, not now, I guess.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Okay.
I'm gonna try...
Oh my god.
Oh, shoot.
Put away your gun.
It's the 14th in EU time zones, which means I'm officially a hag now.
How do I deal with being in demand?
Vtuber fans keep sliding in my DMs.
Please help me, Ms. Boomer.
Chovek!
Happy birthday!
Happy in my foot!
Birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Chovek.
You're a hag now.
Happy birthday to you.
Wait, what's a male hag?
You're a bag now.
You're...
A hog?
I'm not gonna beat him this time, I don't think guys, because...
Oh my god.
Ah, shoot.
This
attack so much.
Come on, I'm trying.
Oh my gosh.
I can't avoid bullets ever.
It's just in my nature.
Why always in the foot?
He's such a freak.
He's just a freak, he's just a freak.
They're all just freaks.
Two minutes left.
Yeah, I know.
It's OK, we're not gonna get him this time.
If I don't get him.
Am I out of bullets?
I mean, I just gotta move.
Wait, did I cure it?
No.
What did I miss?
What do you mean?
Not yet.
Oh, disinfect.
Disinfect.
I can't CQC him in this mode though, or can I?
I'll try when he's not so... When he's not in the green glow, you know.
Unless I can do it here.
Yeah, OK.
Use Mosin if you are out of unlethal gun.
But it's like...
It's so hard to shoot with it though.
I have a broken bone?
Since when?
What else do I need?
Oh, bandage.
Easy peasy.
Yesterday was my bday.
I'm already a male hag.
Just a hag older.
Can I get your infamous bday song?
Only you twirls a U at the end.
What do you mean?
Happy birthday too!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Yonatan with a Y.
Happy hag...
One minute baby!
OK, maybe I will try the Mosin.
You know what?
It doesn't hurt to try new things.
Let's get... I can't get rid of you.
Let's put you away.
I don't need you.
Oh boy.
I feel like this is not going to end well for me, but...
Stop!
I'm so sick of this.
He is like... He has so much health, you guys.
I think I might just... I think it would just be rather...
I think it would just be better to do lethal, right?
Honestly, I'm not even going to cure because it's just...
Snake is hungry?
I'll let him eat though.
We can eat.
We can have a rat.
Snake is so tricky.
It's like I'm too slow.
Oh my gosh.
Hey!
Stop it!
We're done, though.
Shoot him in the face when you knock him down.
OK.
Let's change our camouflage.
What if I put on... Wait, can I put on Rykov's outfit and he goes like...
Isn't that a thing?
I put on Rykov's outfit and he gets all like...
There's a little wig.
He gets like kind of... He's like... That's my guy.
I remember that too.
OK, we'll just keep it like this for now.
Let's...
Oh,
wait.
I can't CQC in this though, can I?
Ivan.
I forgot I can't CQC.
I just ran up to him and was like...
Shoot!
Oh, thank you.
And then... Shoot!
In the butt!
Oh my gosh.
Fancy tricks.
Wait!
Got him in the butt?
Oh man.
OK.
I got him in the butt.
I got a broken bone.
Getting him in the butt.
Splint.
Band-Aid.
All cured.
Oh my gosh!
Every time!
Wait.
Oh shoot.
Whatever.
I always get him in the butt, baby.
It's my specialty.
Oh
shoot.
I thought he was going to disengage.
I thought he was not going to be electric anymore.
OK, he's... He has...
Ouch!
Every time!
Same thing.
Thanks Ocelot.
Ocelot is the best.
My best wingman.
Or hype man.
Sorry.
Ocelot is my best hype man.
Noodle time!
Throw a snake at him?
I don't have a snake.
All my stuff is empty.
I think I used to have one.
Maybe Eva ate it.
What if I threw a vampire bat at him?
Probably wouldn't care.
Frogs?
What about the frogs?
Throw a tree frog.
Try a poison.
Will he eat it?
Tasted bad.
The frogs need to be alive.
Oh he's scared of frogs?
Wait, seriously?
Eva ate your snake?
Oh my.
Wait, seriously?
He's afraid of frogs?
I had no idea.
Why do I need to eat the Russian glow cap though?
I didn't use anything.
Use the glow caps.
Glowing mush attracts lightning.
Oh, like throw the glow.
So it's like have it...
That's the reason behind shooting the hidden keros.
No way, because he's afraid of the frogs?
I didn't know that.
You learn something every time.
OK...
I'm trying!
He needs to stop being so glowy.
Oh, wait, can I get him now?
Oh my God.
Oh
my gosh, I seriously get hit every time!
You guys!
Phase 2.
Phase 2, baby.
Shoot him!
He's like you told me not to interact.
Do you hear me?
I said shoot him!
Sorry, Colonel.
I'm afraid I can't do that.
What do you mean you can't?
I made a promise to the boss.
Silence!
I am your commanding officer.
He's so weak.
We should be able to beat him easy.
My authority.
So awesome.
Yes!
Rattle!
The sass.
I love Ocelot like no one else ever.
Yes!
Stop!
Don't look at me like that!
No, hold on!
Wait, I think I need to cure.
Yeah, hold on.
Hold on, Logan.
He did nothing.
Oh my God!
He's just...he's just him!
OK.
Oh gosh.
Phase 2.
Ouch!
Oh my gosh, I just...I just...I just did that.
How am I supposed to avoid that?
OK.
Ouch!
Oh my God!
Wait!
OK, so when he lifts his hand up in the air...
Like you just don't care.
I have to care.
I have to get down on the ground.
Crawl, yeah.
Wait, no, this is not down on the air.
Oh shit!
Oh my gosh, I'm such an idiot.
Hold on, I'm going to use my cure thing.
Wait, it's in here.
I'm going to use my life med.
It's not much, but...
It's maybe enough.
OK.
Oh gosh, we have 2 minutes left.
Oh shoot!
Shoot his butt!
I
think I'm stupid.
OK.
Alright.
Oh gosh.
Come on!
Logan please, let me shoot you.
But
I'm not going to risk it otherwise.
Oh God!
Oh shoot, I didn't realize it was a double.
No!
Trank, man.
Panic
a little, but it was more so that it's hard to get like...
It's hard to get shots.
Dang it.
From the beginning, right?
Wait.
I don't think you should first person.
I have to or else it doesn't aim for him.
Otherwise it doesn't aim for him.
Unless I'm just dumb, I don't know.
You're having trouble drawing your gun to hit him when he's down.
Yeah, I am.
I am.
Maybe I should try and hit him twice.
If I have time to get him while he's down.
It's because after you CQC him, there's a brief...
There's a very brief point where you can't equip the gun.
So I'm thinking I have to equip the gun...
Or rather, I have to have the gun equipped when I CQC him.
So that it's already prepped.
I think that's what I...
Have to... Yeah, equip before CQC.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I think that's where we will get a little bit better.
But why do you unequip?
Because it says if you have it equipped, it will explode.
He explodes the bullets and then it hurts you.
So I just unequip it.
Because it's easier, I guess.
I don't know.
Yeah, I have everything in here.
He took out all her MK22 ammo on the first run.
Yeah, because he blew it up.
Yeah, Vulcan does an attack that blows up your gun and makes you lose ammo.
Yep, yep, yep.
Yep, yep.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Okay, alright.
The music.
I'm dodging.
Oh shoot.
Oh my God.
Oh shoot, I forgot.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, I got two at least.
Here what comes?
What's coming?
Who's coming?
What is this?
What is this move?
What are you doing?
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I should run towards him during that bar.
Okay, are we gonna do anything?
Vulcan!
Thank you!
I love you so much!
Come
on, let me CQC you please.
Can I shoot him here?
I could've.
I'm seeking.
Okay, okay.
I'm testing stuff out guys.
Can you summon stuff?
Oh, don't, don't, don't.
Oh shoot!
That was too slow.
Gosh, I'm not close enough to him.
Every time.
Wait, am I losing my bullets?
I can't tell.
Am I losing my bullets when I get hit by him?
I don't know.
No?
Okay, cool.
Oh fucking hell!
Guys, I think I'm just gonna restart.
Kill me!
I
just wanna restart you guys.
I don't wanna keep going.
I wanna restart.
Can you just kill me?
Just kill me.
See?
Be
up on your butt.
What if I'm just up on your butt the whole time?
If you can't have me on my hat, you don't deserve me on my Judo.
Let's heal.
I mean, I might as well try.
So funny.
So many gunshot wounds.
Snake, are you okay?
Let's eat.
Just go all in on the face.
Yeah baby!
Actually no, I'm gonna eat the ramen.
For you Snake.
A delicious meal.
That's damn good.
My gosh!
Disinfect.
What am I using?
For bleeding.
There we go.
The stick.
Oh shoot.
He was good for like 2 seconds.
Oh my gosh.
Everything is bad.
Before
I shoot him.
I don't think this is the run either guys.
Let me cure while I'm at it.
The auto aim seems to be very questionable.
I know, he just shoots in the middle of the room.
This is the run.
We almost clutched that.
That was so close man.
We are getting closer every time.
Every time baby.
It's okay.
It's only...
It's alright.
We got this guys.
We got this.
I believe.
I mean I have to.
I have to beat the game eventually.
I have to.
Will Rykov actually give us extra hits?
Do I have to... I just put on the mask right?
Oh wait.
Let's see what he does.
Here it comes.
Thank you.
Thanks Ivan.
Alright.
Oh sh**, sh**, sh**!
Oh my gosh.
No!
Get him, get him, get him!
Get him!
Oh shoot.
Come on!
Please!
Shoot him!
And shoot!
All that I could get.
Keep it up.
Thank you!
Thanks!
Thanks Ocelot.
I really appreciate when you tell me good things.
Really appreciate it when you tell me good things.
It really motivates me Ocelot!
Solid hits, good combo.
Thank you!
Why aren't you using the thermal goggles?
Alright.
Oh gosh, it scared me for a second.
I was like hello?
Hello?
I feel like there should be a Mint vs Bosses funny compilation.
Is this funny to you?
Is my afterlife a joke to you?
I strive to one day find someone who looks at me the same way Ocelot looks at Snake.
That's why I love Ocelot so much.
I get him, you know.
I get him.
He recovers so much more quickly, you know.
Please!
Oh shoot.
OK.
He's doing it again, right?
Shoot.
I need to really get into him.
I got low ammo.
I do have low ammo.
If I can get some...
Oh my gosh.
Ocelot!
Oh shoot.
I don't think Ocelot throws this kind of ammo though, does he?
Oh my god.
Watch out!
Dang it!
You idiot!
Will the sick spray work?
OK.
Let's try it.
We are almost out.
He blew up my ammo.
He blew it up!
How am I supposed to...
I have so much time.
I have so much time, but I need to...
Oh shoot.
I thought he was...
Oh shoot!
There we go.
I'm hungry.
Oh gosh.
This fight seems really frustrating.
It's actually not so bad.
It's that I'm doing it in a more difficult way because I'm doing it non-lethal.
If I was doing it lethal, I would be able to use the big guns and it would be way more faster, but...
This is my first time, well actually this is my second time ever fighting this guy.
Playing this game.
And it's always my first time ever doing non-lethal, so...
You know, I'm gonna be a little clumsy about it.
Does that work?
He like blocks it.
Is it actually working?
Oh shoot!
He's like blocking it though.
Nice.
It works?
OK, I'm gonna do this.
I was...
Too slow.
See?
Oh my gosh.
Alright, hold on.
This is desperate times.
We have 30 seconds left.
Oh gosh!
No more ammo.
This left, but we have the Mosin.
In the corner?
Like that corner?
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no, no.
Like this corner.
Oh
no!
He's doing it, he's doing it.
Oh gosh.
I don't
have any confidence in this right now.
Oh shoot.
I gotta get down.
Literally one hit away.
One hit away.
So close.
I gotta pick up the...
I have to pick up the other ammo more...
Quickly.
Ah...
How did you fumble it at the end like that?
Oh, I don't know.
You know, it's just...
It's a Minto staple, you know.
It's OK.
Oh, what the?
I'm your boyfriend!
Oh yeah, see?
Ah, hold on.
You know, be nice to me you guys.
Come on.
Don't be rude.
People fumble.
Also, I'm streaming.
It's like completely different.
If you've never streamed and played a game before, it's like you don't understand...
The first like...
The...
What's it called?
The performance anxiety that you get.
And then, also, I'm just like, you know...
Oh shoot, I thought it was gonna...
Oh my gosh.
I try...
I try every time.
I literally do try every time.
Don't roll, but otherwise...
I get hit anyway.
I run, I get hit.
Nothing works for me.
I didn't
even notice.
Please, shoot him!
Shoot him!
Ok, we got the first bit down, you know.
Well, almost.
Kinda.
You know, I can get there.
It's just...
It's just the second part.
Round 2, baby.
Really?
Right
where you're going to.
Can you not?
Ah, see!
Oh my God.
Oh shoot!
I tried.
So close!
You guys are so close.
Oh, I don't like this one actually.
Shoot him while he's down!
Shoot!
Dang it.
Come on, Volcan!
Oh, I think I could've.
Maybe I could've.
Actually, I'm not sure.
He's all charged.
No!
C3 Explosives!
I have like one hit on this guy.
Please.
Oh,
I got him.
I got a CQC on him.
And shoot him!
Shoot him!
Yippee!
Shoot him while he's down.
Assume the position, Volcan.
What?
Should I just kick him in the butt?
Yeah!
I tried to kick him in the butt.
Yeah, baby!
Alright.
One of three boss fights to go.
One of three ending boss fights to go.
Let's go.
I don't even have to heal this time.
Go, Snake, go!
I wish I could...I want to see the...
The camo he gave me.
My Oshi is a gamer.
Thank you.
Congrats on getting an OP uniform.
Thank you!
First time defeating him non-lethal.
Everybody run!
And also I'm like...I'm like four hours of sleep.
I'm not doing so bad I guess.
We're all gonna die!
I can't with him.
He's just absolutely the perfect freak in my life, in my afterlife.
Oh, Ocelot!
I wish I had known you when I was alive.
I'm so gachikoi for him in like the least romantic way.
I don't know how to explain it.
There's just something about Ocelot in my brain that I just can't...I just can't!
We throw down bad, but no!
It's just...I don't know.
I just get him so much.
Instant knife!
Thanks for the ten kisses!
He's like my soulmate, but not in a romantic way.
You know, I understand him so much.
Simp recognize simp.
Don't give up!
Sorry, it sucks.
They're just so dramatic about it.
What?
I've still got one last job to do.
The boss is already at the lake.
She's at the lake.
She's waiting for you there.
Waiting for me?
Maybe we shouldn't go.
I was hoping I wouldn't have to tell you.
Bad things are exploding.
I don't want you to fight her.
But I...I've come to realize that there's a special relationship between you two.
Something I can't understand.
Something that goes beyond a man and a woman.
Oh, I envy you.
Really, I do.
But I guess I just can't understand it.
Thanks for the ten kisses!
She asked me to tell you something.
I've never seen someone with such clear eyes.
There.
I said it.
What did she ask to tell me, though?
Ready to go?
Wait, she didn't say it.
Oh boy.
Uh-oh, what could that be?
Is that...
No way!
So it's not...
Shacklehide!
No!
Metal Gear?
No, this isn't Metal Gear.
This is Shacklehide.
Not yet, Snake!
It's not over yet!
Not good.
You guys, I forgot another boss battle.
Actually, that we also have to do.
I forgot another boss battle we have to do.
Before we...
Ok, hold on.
I want to change into the new camo.
Ok guys, heads or tails?
Heads or tails?
Heads?
Tails?
Ok.
Oh wait, he's going to throw up.
Heads!
What does this do?
Don't puke on Eva.
Oh, he didn't puke.
He's stronger now.
It's actually Vulcan's underwear?
Snake, can you explain to me why is this broken?
It wasn't strong enough.
No!
They emptied it.
Oh, they don't shoot you if they see you.
Oh my gosh.
Can you face them?
They aggravate with the American side.
Ok, that's what I thought would happen.
That's so funny.
It's all yours.
Hold on.
I've never heard these before actually.
Now I think about it.
They don't shoot.
If they catch up to you, you're dead.
You've got to get away from them.
I've never heard these.
I don't think I've ever called them.
The M63, yeah.
We got this.
Ok.
Change the camera angle and enjoy the absolute cinema.
Oh yeah, that's right.
Infinite ammo.
Let's get our big guns out, baby.
The big guns out.
Put you away.
You, baby.
Alright.
Guns a blazing.
Wait, this is so cool.
Wait, this is so awesome.
I am, I'm shooting, I'm shooting, I'm shooting.
Oh my god, it looks so awesome.
Wait, can you turn around, Sync?
Sync, turn the other way.
Sync, turn.
Turn that way.
There you go.
Hit literally anybody, please.
Ok, I'll try first person maybe.
Oh, but I want to see these angles.
They are so awesome.
It's like a movie reel.
Normal angles, it's just like this.
Like you're just traveling with it, right?
But with this it kind of moves, you know?
It's so good.
This camera angle is awesome!
I feel like they should have changed it.
Oh no!
Maybe we...
Those are your men, Volgin!
Let's head for the rail bridge.
And then blow it up!
RPG.
I don't have that.
Puzzle!
He would have made that.
It's just a baby.
You don't... You're not good enough yet.
Sorry, I can't get over it.
It's so funny.
It's like too strange.
Hold on, Snake!
Nice, Snake.
You're missing a boot.
Oh my god!
Uh oh.
Nice, nice.
Nice.
You know, they chose a scene in the trailer for Delta of him protecting Ocelot from the falling debris.
Do you understand?
I'm just shooting.
I'm just blasting.
Oh, uh...
Thank
you, Eva.
She's so encouraging.
Nice.
Yeah, I got it, Eva.
Cinematic camera angles, baby!
Yippee!
Can't hit anything.
Eva, keep it up!
She's a pacifist, you guys.
Don't you know?
She's a pacifist.
She's like, oh yeah.
Don't kill them, Snake.
Nice.
I'm showing off.
Turn around, Snake.
Don't stop.
Why does the Shagohot have drill arms?
It's like a little... It's like a beaver.
Not a beaver.
A groundhog.
OK, Shagohot is pretty cute.
Oh my god, she's doing the work for me.
Thanks, Shagohot!
For the same reason anime girls have drill hair.
Because it's cute.
Shagohot is cute.
Oh, also for this thing too.
Make it go really fast.
That's what the drill arms are for.
Eva, we might want to get out of the way.
I'm just saying.
Eva, we might...
What a mood.
We might want to get out of the way, Eva.
Can't
get a single bike.
Just a little up, Snake.
There we go.
Oh,
there's several more guys.
Oh man.
Oh my god, these camera angles are crazy.
I'm
saying everything and nothing!
That's the American way.
I have the Star Trooper!
Slowly but surely.
Arsemity screws.
They work on water and ice.
The idea is that they can use the Shagohot anywhere.
Even on lakes, I think.
Watch out!
He's so big.
I love Josh Keaton's performance in this game so much.
It's everything I could hope for.
Again!
Nice, good job.
OK, just like...
Eva,
I'm scared!
OK, so this is the...
One moment.
I
don't have any RPG.
I don't even have that, do I?
When did I get an RPG?
In the cutscene.
Watch out, Ocelot!
Sorry if I hit you!
No, I'm not!
I don't know where I'm supposed to go.
Now we made it.
Shoot the treads.
Oh, I was shooting the little wheelies.
The little...whatever.
It's all good, though.
This part is not super...you know.
Eva, floor it!
Nice.
Nice dodge.
This thing is so maneuverable.
The bridge.
Let's go.
Snake, we've only got one chance.
We'll lure him over towards the other side.
Oh, that's right.
When the Shagohata is on the bridge, shoot the explosives.
The bomb is planted on the strut of the bridge.
One chance!
Is it on the PS2 version?
Yeah, I'm playing the PS2 version now.
No pressure.
Just don't do it too early.
Of course, not too late.
We've got one chance.
And it will totally make a difference in this fight.
It will 100% mean that we win.
Definitively.
I hate this part.
Gives me such false hope.
All I see is boobies.
OK, it's on the strut.
Alright,
Snake.
Find it and shoot it.
It's...
It's... Where?
Hello?
Oh...
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Is it here?
OK, just tell me when it's here.
OK, tell me when.
Say when.
OK, thanks Eva.
Oh, shoot.
I shot it!
Asalatsu's face is not looking so great.
Yeah, we did it!
We don't have to fight him now!
Yeah, it's over.
Said everybody.
When it's actually over.
This powerpuff girl's music.
And
I'm going to stay on the bike the entire time!
For luck.
Guys, she kissed me.
Did you see that?
P.O.V.
Eva kisses you.
So awesome.
Oh my God, the music is so awesome!
OK, hold on.
I must say...
Yes, Eva... I mean Paramedic.
Sorry.
I'm so used to saying Eva's name.
Just in case something happens.
What if I lose power?
I don't know.
I'm scared.
Eva on the mine.
I can't help it.
She just gave me a big ol' smooch.
Alright Paramedic, what movie are you going to tell us about?
While we are mid-combat with a pseudo-Metal Gear.
Good luck.
The rear frame of the Shagohod was destroyed when the bridge collapsed.
The back side of the front frame is now exposed.
Get in the butt!
Even the Shagohod is bound to have less armor plating on its back side.
I'm sure you can penetrate it with the RPG-7.
In the butt.
Attack the Shagohod from behind with the RPG-7.
Got it.
The Shagohod's weapons are deadly.
You're likely to get seriously hurt if you get caught in its sights.
If you get injured, go into the survival view and take care of it immediately.
The machine gun on that thing is deadly.
But you can force him to break off his attack by firing the RPG-7 at the body of the Shagohod.
If he starts strafing you with the machine gun, pump a rocket into the Shagohod before you get turned into Swiss cheese.
OK I don't like this fight.
Switch to the sneak suit.
Yeah.
We're gonna switch to that.
Cause we're gonna be needing its little abilities.
Guess we don't need...
If only he would just not shoot at me, huh?
OK
Did you?
Ah!
Where's the bag?
Eva, get me to the bag, please.
OK.
I actually am wasting my ammo.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
No!
Eva, I need you to get me to the bag.
Eva!
Swiss cheese!
Get us to the bag.
There we go.
Madrid!
Wait, Eva, can you please?
Eva.
Eva!
Why is he getting invincibility frames?
Please!
Yippee!
Alright, phase one down, baby.
OK
I hate this part, though.
I hate this part.
No.
The turrets.
Yeah, but I'm not good at using those.
I don't quite remember what's like the best way to do this one.
Yeah, phase two is rough.
If you get the Mosin-3 headshots, you're deadly.
Really?
OK, let's try it.
The sniper?
OK.
I'll do my best.
Luckily, phase one isn't so bad.
Look at that ass!
Shooting the frogs on the...
I hate this idea, Eva.
I absolutely hate it.
Eva, you annoy me so much here.
No!
Watch the pinkies!
I love this part.
Yeah!
You tell him, Eva!
You tell him!
OK, I'm scared of this part, truly, you guys.
I'm so scared.
This part always gives me such pain.
Come on snake!
Snake, this is our opportunity!
Switch!
Motion?
I can't unequip you.
Let's get rid of our Cigar Gas Spray.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
We have two more bosses after this.
We have two more.
Unequip the fork, you animal.
No!
I'm hungry!
One more?
We got two more.
Don't you know that escort missions are impossible themselves?
I'm calling the escort a boss.
Unequip the rotten food.
We can get rid of that too, can't we?
But it's OK.
I have everything that I need right now.
Alright.
Oh gosh!
Oh my God.
Oh God, he's really fast, guys.
Oh my gosh.
Oh God.
Eva, just keep at him, please!
Just keep at him, please!
Oh my God.
Oh gosh!
So bad.
I can't...I'm seeing the sky.
Can I...also...can I still take out his...
OK.
The frames.
I don't think so.
Believe that.
OK, so we can.
Awesome.
A trench.
Is he avoiding?
Is he, like, dodging my attack?
Let's wait for him to do his little spin around.
Of course, this is not...you know.
Oh, please.
Will this count as a bag?
Eva, don't get...What are you doing?
Eva!
Oh shit.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is actually my...
OK, OK.
OK.
Can you, like, not stop...start attacking me until, like, I...
start getting hits on you first, you know?
Eva, you were supposed to be distracting him!
So unfair.
Burn.
What was that?
Ointment?
I...notice me, right?
Can you, like, stop viewing me first?
Oh, that's a...
Oh my god.
Eva!
Please do something!
She
did something, you guys.
She did something.
OK, OK.
Oh my god.
My gosh.
She did something.
She did do something.
Good job, Eva!
OK.
I don't care.
I don't care about...
Oh my god, wait.
We got him!
Nice.
Oh, that did mega damage.
DD Megadoodoo.
Just gonna keep running around until he wins the
game.
Go back to Eva, please.
Eva, don't run me over.
Eva, don't run...
How'd that get me?
I don't know.
What else do I need?
Oh, the bandage.
I'm starting to think Eva is a double agent.
Double agent.
He eventually blows up the... What's it called?
The machine guns, I believe.
Don't get stuck on the fence!
Eva, Eva, Eva, Eva.
Eva, can I get back on your bike, please?
Eva!
Eva, Eva.
Oh gosh.
That wasn't very kind of you.
That wasn't very kind of you, Volgin.
Let's run away while that's covering for me.
These eventually explode.
Oh, OK.
This is fine.
Eva,
someone can just hit you.
Again.
Doing your job.
Oh, I missed.
My bad.
Don't mind me.
Sorry, Eva.
Give it up on tranking him.
Yeah, it's OK.
I don't need to.
Please, please, please, please, please, please.
Oh my god.
First try, baby!
Cool, bye.
You're a little trickster, you, Volgin.
Yeah, I want to see you use your lightning powers in the rain.
I think you are!
I think you're the one afraid of a little thunder.
You little baby.
You're always trying to ward it off.
Phase 3.
Eva's surprised Pikachu face is too good.
He catches on fire.
Oh my god, all the bullets exploding into him.
That's crazy!
Such a lust for revenge.
Him!
They just keep going.
I think we might want to stay away from him.
What a way to go.
Guys, we did it!
Oh my gosh, fireworks!
Yippee!
This guy's body is literally exploding and we're like...
Happy 4th of July!
Happy New Year!
Does the Volgin camo work again here?
Lucky!
Bye Volgin!
See you again never.
Yeah, it works.
Perfect.
Let's change into that.
They fly now?
Oh, they've been flying.
I killed a guy like that.
I put him to sleep.
One moment.
Camouflage.
You guys...
Oh, and let's switch out our weapons.
Let's go back to the M60.
Oh, my bad.
Let's go back to...
We'll unequip these for now.
What if we kiss in front of the exploding Russian?
Back to Fork?
Always!
I always have my Fork equipped.
So cinematic.
Oh, my gosh.
I can't see anything.
You guys, this motion blur is actually insane.
I can't see...
Oh, my God.
Holy motion blur.
For real though.
It's so bad.
Are they in front of us now?
These camera angles are killing me.
They are so funny.
Did you hear him in the distance?
Somewhere out there a snake is going...
Oh, my gosh.
Where are they?
In front of us?
Enemy sighted!
Let's just sit forward.
Ah...
Snake, where are you shooting at?
That's the one thing about these camera angles is that I literally can't tell where I'm shooting at.
Rain muffled his last rhyme.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, gosh.
I can't see anything.
Oh, my God.
I can't... Oh, my gosh.
Damn it.
I don't know if I'm shooting, if I'm hitting.
I know they told me to use first person.
Fine, I'll use first person.
Oh, my God.
Damn it.
Me too.
I can't even hit shit.
I can't aim.
Where are you guys?
Oh, my
God.
Where are you?
I can't even tell where I'm shooting.
I'll be honest.
I don't even know.
Where is the log?
I'm shooting the log, Eva!
I'm shooting the log.
I got it.
Where are the other guys?
Damn it.
Whatever.
Oh, can you use the size of the M63?
It's all too craziness.
It can't even... The motion blur plus the recoil plus...
Everything is just making it impossible for me.
Oh, my God.
These camera angles are killing me.
These are the old camera angles, which are great, but like...
Holy moly.
It is... Oh, my God.
I can't see anything.
Are there people?
I don't think so.
Oh, yes there are.
I can't see where I'm shooting because I don't know which direction I'm going.
Sometimes when the camera angle changes...
Am I shooting... Am I shooting to the left?
Am I shooting to the right?
I don't know.
The camera angle just changes so much.
Everything is wild!
Everything is too crazy!
Can I... Am I shooting anybody?
I can't even tell.
I think I'm getting them eventually.
Eventually.
Oh, my God.
Where are they now?
Nobody knows.
Am I shooting straight?
I don't know.
Do I move my analog stick to the left or the right?
I have no idea!
Eva!
Eva.
Distant Eva.
Oh, my gosh.
I can't hear you, Eva!
You're all the way over there!
This is so insanity.
It's just...
I don't know.
Oh, no.
Eva, you don't want to drive so fast in the forest.
Be careful.
Oh, no.
It's not my fault, is it?
It's your fault, Eva.
I had the good camo on.
Eva!
Oh, gosh.
Snake, are you okay?
I didn't blow up the log.
It's my fault.
Legend has it that this RAW wasn't intended.
It was recorded on a hot mic after David Hayter was told he would have to record a MGS2 type codec.
Source sounds cool.
Eva, are you okay?
Oh, goodness.
You spooked me.
You're still alive.
Eva!
Eva.
Snake.
What an inconvenience.
How's it look?
Pretty bad.
Not a sensitive bone in your body.
Eva.
What about you, Snake?
I'm fine.
That's good to hear.
No.
Goodbye.
Oh boy.
Boss number 2.
2 out of 4.
Wait, 3 out of 4.
Okay.
Hold on, I'm going to close my eyes and kind of Yume Joshi here a little bit, okay?
Is it alright?
What do you mean?
Say that one more time.
This guy is so stupid.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I guess so.
Alright.
Oh gosh.
Oh my god.
Eva, please.
Eva.
Oh my gosh.
We should have just torn off the stick and then walked with the stick in her body, right?
I feel like that would have been better to stop the bleeding.
Right?
If we tore the stick off and didn't just...
We should have cut it off.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Eva.
Snake.
Now it's just open.
Snake, can you hear me?
Yeah.
End game tutorial.
Calm down.
Do you know about the easter egg with Eva?
I kind of.
I know about it, but I don't quite remember how to access it.
I think so.
Yeah.
Okay.
Paramedic doesn't want any competition.
Eva's such a drama queen.
Being stabbed in the kidney makes her cough blood.
Cure.
Cure snake.
We gotta cut.
We gotta disinfect.
Oh my gosh.
What do you mean running short?
Snake, we are full.
What are you talking about?
I'm running low.
They gave us everything.
What else?
Not the ointment.
Switcher.
My favorite segment of the game.
I hope they implement this more in Delta.
Make this a 10 hour segment, please.
Guys, boss fight number 3 coming up.
Baby, love that.
Love that for us.
I love that for us.
What do I need?
Burn?
Wait, what?
Oh no bandage.
Bandage.
Where is the bandage?
Oh there it is.
Putting an escort mission right before the very end.
Why Kojima?
Why?
Eva.
They are so perky.
Look at them grippers.
How do I see her...
Her medical history.
Isn't that where it's at?
Like all the stuff that she's...
Check medical history.
How do I get to it?
R2?
No.
In surgery?
Here?
Where is it?
Finish the tutorial first.
OK, I'm getting ahead of myself.
I'm getting ahead of myself.
Bandage disinfectant.
R1?
Oh wait.
Oh my God.
Eva?
Are you OK?
Are you OK Eva?
Oh there it is.
There it is.
Thank you guys.
We got a cut, stab wound, gunshot wound, burn...
Proctitis.
What's that?
Lower back pain?
I mean that's just every lady isn't it?
Love a girl with a good set of bones.
Any skeletons in the chat?
Finger sprain, stomach ache, leech, broken nail.
Tummy hurt.
Can Eva barf if you spin her around?
I'm not sure.
Blow sustained.
Is that...
Together with the lower back pain?
Proctitis is inflammation of the rectum.
Electrical burn.
Blow sustained.
Hypoxia.
A cold.
Stomach ache.
Broken nail.
Cold.
Stomach ache.
Inner ear infection.
Oh that sucks.
A cavity.
Oh no.
Night terror.
Gastritis.
Stomach ache.
She's got a lot of tummy aches.
A breast enhancement.
That's why they're so perky.
You know what?
They look natural.
They look good.
Bronchitis.
Tick-borne encephalitis.
A cut.
Frostbite?
Eva how?
Stab wound spread.
What about the... Is the stab wound the tree maybe?
Let's see what she's got in her food history.
Instant noodles.
Some grappa.
I hardly even know her.
Grilled duck breast with herbs.
Gorgonzola cream.
She's eating good.
Fettuccine.
Some tea.
Tsuchinoko and shark fin soup.
She's eating good.
Cold vegetables.
Apple.
Instant noodles.
Coffee.
Gulova cream brulee.
With a milk sorbet.
Oh my gosh.
Saffron soup style.
Duck foie gras sauteed in apple sauce.
Baguette.
She ate that mushroom.
She got the chilled ratatouille.
Fried with... Oyster mushroom fried with dandelions.
Oh my gosh, it's just non-stop.
I think she's eating better than I've ever eaten in my entire afterlife.
Wow.
Okay, I'll help you now, Eva.
She's suffering... Abdomen pierced by the tree branch.
Don't remember what you've got.
Okay, let's see.
We need to stop the bleeding.
Disinfecting.
Perfect.
Oh, spinner?
Spinner?
Oh wait.
Oh my gosh, I almost didn't notice.
Bleeding.
Maybe I can still do it.
I wouldn't have done it anyway because of the cutscene.
Snake's food history is like rat, rat, bat, frog.
I think so.
Starting to get sleepy, you guys.
Look at him.
He doesn't even have to do anything and he's just so calm and cool.
She's looking at him like, what the hell is the time?
It's now the time, I know.
But he's telling her something important!
She needs to use it, you know?
Okay, hold on.
Let's see.
Oh no, I can't go back to Eva, can I?
Wait, if I go to cure...Oh, there we go.
Whoa.
Yes?
I'm fine.
Yeah, I've been better.
She just barked all over the place.
Okay.
If I tell her to jump off a bridge too, will she do it?
But I'm like, hey Eva!
Let's go here.
She'll do it.
Eva doesn't seem very smart.
We're full on everything.
Crazy.
You okay, Eva?
God, she's so beautiful.
Don't die, Eva.
You're too hot to die, okay?
Look, she's recovering.
She's recovering.
Let's recover together.
Just woke up?
Oh, sorry.
I'm sore?
Thank you for doing the concert with me and the great UQ.
Thank you!
Eva, this is for my stamina.
Eva, this is for me.
I think you enjoy this, madam.
You've been all over me.
This entire time you've been all over Snake.
Oh my god, her stamina goes down crazy fast.
Let's feed her real quick.
What you like?
A rat.
Look with respect.
Alrighty.
If you really loved her, you would feed her a rat.
Alright, guys.
Whoa!
Holy framerate.
Oh my goodness.
Okay, I think we're... Oh, goodness.
What is... What's the framerate?
Alright, Eva.
Oh, let me change my... Wait!
If I'm wearing this, they still won't be able to shoot me, right?
So...
My PS2 is like...
The rain!
Any guys?
I don't know.
I don't remember where they're at, so...
They just point their guns and say, damn it.
Yeah.
They're so silly.
But then I still don't want to cause an alert, you know?
Oh, save.
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, just in case my PS2 is just like...
Won't they still shoot Eva?
I guess you're right.
It's probably for the best that we don't wear it.
No guys still after cutscene?
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
We're so close to the end.
We're almost there.
Thank you, paramedic.
Thank you.
It's another easter egg if you feed Eva oodles... noodles.
Really?
Oodles and noodles.
But these are mine.
I just wasted them.
Why wouldn't it let me...
Oops.
The save.
Am I too far?
It wouldn't let me give it to...Oh.
Eva, come here.
What are you doing over there?
How do I get her to follow me?
Action button?
Come on, Eva.
Oh yeah, hold on.
Let me also change.
Camouflage.
Oh, no.
Let's go with this one.
Camouflage.
We're in the woods.
Wait.
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
Finally!
I get to use the moss!
Wait a second.
Why is spirit better than moss?
Fine.
What was what?
What was what, Eva?
What are you talking about?
The snake?
Oh my gosh.
That's what that was.
It's like Simon says with her.
Monkey see, monkey do.
Feed her the snake.
We're gonna feed you everything, Eva.
We want all your reactions, okay?
Come here.
Where are you?
Oh, come here!
Come here!
Why can't I carry you?
Just let me carry you, man.
Oh, so it was because she was too far away.
Would you like a reticulated python?
I want some more!
If I drank her...
Might be worth it.
Eva, get over here!
Eva!
Eva, please.
Okay, thank you.
Can I have seconds?
Wait, I can't tell by the map.
This way?
Yeah.
Come on!
Where are you?
What are you doing over there?
Come here!
No!
Okay.
Alrighty.
Sorry about missing the...
I really don't want to restart my PS2.
I'll be honest, guys.
Sorry about missing the noodles.
I thought...
I thought it would give me the option to...
Give it to her after I clicked it.
I forgot.
Sorry.
Alrighty.
We got a whole horde of guys here.
Wait, did they come from behind?
I hate this part.
Escort mission.
Yeah, I honestly don't remember this song at all either.
Maybe because I just try not to think about this whole entire segment of the game.
Where are they coming from?
Behind?
Alright, come on, Eva.
Eva, come on.
Eva, let's go.
Eva!
Oh gosh.
Eva, get in the grass.
Come here, Eva.
Grass time.
It's grass time.
Okay, Eva.
Are they going to see her or...
Oh, okay.
I'll leave this to you.
I'm not murdering them.
She is.
Oh shoot.
Hold on.
Anyway, so I started a blacklisting.
They are not going to stop, Eva.
We just gotta go.
These guys suck.
Eva, Eva, come here.
What's wrong?
Yeah, what's wrong?
Go check on your buddy first.
What's wrong?
Come on, Eva.
Right there?
Right where?
Under... Where?
Eva, come on.
Come on, Eva.
Let's just walk nice and slow.
They'll never notice us.
Oh, Eva, you need some food?
I don't wanna hear... She sounds like Mario.
I'm retired.
It tasted bad, but I can give you... I got a lot of tree frogs.
These also taste bad.
Wait, hold on.
We gotta...
Come here.
I'll give you something to eat.
I'll give you... I'll give you something to eat.
A Russian ration.
I know.
Alright, let's keep going.
We do?
No, we don't.
Come here.
Just keep going.
Keep walking, Eva.
Eva.
I'm gonna need you to keep...
moving, okay?
Just a little bit at a time.
It's all good, okay?
Just keep going, Eva.
Yeah, come on.
I got my big guns.
You got your guns.
We're going.
We're guns blazing.
No, nobody's here.
Just your imagination.
Come on, Eva.
I just fed you!
Eva!
You're gonna take all my food.
I am so...
You know what, Eva?
You get all the tree frogs.
I'm sorry.
Yuck.
Oh gosh.
Uh-oh.
I think we're in trouble.
She...
is literally gonna take all my food.
What did you give me?
Oh my god.
Let's go.
Come on.
It's...
Yeah, nobody here.
Hold on.
It's up this... It's up here, right?
Yeah.
Come on, Eva.
Eva.
It's literally right here.
Eva, we're so close.
I got her.
Thanks, Major.
An unconscious Eva recovers stamina and faster to drag.
I thought I should've, but you know.
We did it the proper way.
Now I have no food for the boss.
Alright, we got through boss three out of four.
One more.
One more to go.
Oh boy.
I'm getting hungry though.
Oh, nevermind.
Not quite.
Oh shoot, there's more?
Okay.
I need... Hold on.
I need to grab some food, actually.
So we're gonna...
Who's what?
They're gonna see me in the...
Wait, where's the food?
Are they still...
Are they still behind us?
Where are they?
Oh my god.
I thought we were done, guys.
I just thought that was it.
Eva, we need to be faster here, okay?
Eva, we need to...
We need to...
We need to get a move on, okay?
These guys are only gonna be asleep for a little bit.
And I'm gonna grab some food.
Is that good mushroom or bad mushroom?
I guess we'll find out.
Actually, Eva...
Good night.
Okay.
Alright.
Good night, Eva.
Onwards we go...
To the finish...
Okay, girl.
I will get you all instant noodles you can have...
Once we're through...
Here, I'm gonna drag you through the mud a little bit.
Hold your breath.
Okay.
You're fine.
Another mud puddle!
Eva, hold your breath.
Girl, what are you...
Wait, which way am I supposed to go?
I guess it doesn't...
Either way, probably?
Oh my gosh, that's far.
Okay, let's just go this way.
Alright, watch your...
Watch your face.
Watch your face, Eva.
Shh, they're gonna hear you, Eva.
Eva, I need you to be quiet, okay?
Daddy is working.
Calorie, mate.
Okay.
Where are...
Any guys?
I'm wondering if I should check with my thermals real quick.
I went...
The wrong way!
But we can get a bit of an advantage from here, maybe.
Oh, maybe.
What's wrong?
Oh my god.
Please.
Calorie, mate.
This is the ideal date.
Stop!
Hold on, let me put my thermals back on so we can check.
Oh baby, a triple.
I know.
Is that another guy?
Okay, Eva.
Oh boss.
She's really...
She's really feeling herself, huh?
Love that for her.
Okay.
Can I drag her off this cliff?
Alright, Eva.
Let's try.
Oh my god, Snake.
Snake, I need you to run.
Yeah, you're seeing things.
Oh,
hi Kero-tan.
Oh
my gosh.
Where was that other guy though?
Oh, right there.
Okay, Eva.
It was cute for like two seconds, please.
Where is he?
Is that him right there?
Yeah, I see him, I see him.
That's him, that's him.
It's a miracle that he has not noticed any of his friends are down, honestly.
Oh boss, I feel so good.
What did the boss do?
Okay, Eva, let's go.
Turn around.
You can CQC her off the cliff.
Eva, let's go.
Oh, I gotta get you back down.
Okay, Eva.
Good night.
Okay, perfect.
Alright, let's go.
I think we're okay.
I saw something over there, but I think...
Yeah, I think we're okay.
Am I in the right... where?
Girl, shut up.
No way, you can interrogate Eva?
Alright.
Almost there.
Do I have to wake her up?
I want some instant noodles.
Wake up, Eva.
You ready?
Oh my gosh, I just noticed...
Oh my gosh, I just noticed.
I used to last.
Come on.
Come here.
Her hair is brown.
Don't worry about it.
I mean, I'm worried about the wound, honestly, but like...
That's for future Eva to worry about, okay?
I wonder if she'll be all brown and poopy dirty in Delta in the cutscenes.
Okay, was that it?
Please say.
Please be yes.
Are we here?
At the lake?
Oh, now you can run.
What?
Now you can run?
Eva, you are such a drama queen.
She just wanted to be dragged by me.
The music.
Oh, the wig!
Wait.
Oh gosh.
Guys, I'm not ready.
Promise me.
Time for final boss.
Final boss time.
5 FPS.
It's doing its best.
Isn't it beautiful?
It's almost tragic.
When life ends, it gives off a final lingering aroma.
Light is but a farewell gift from the darkness to those on their way to die.
I've been waiting, Snake, for a long time.
Waiting for your birth, your growth, and the finality of today.
Boss, why are you doing this?
Why?
To make the world one again.
The world used to be whole.
But with the end of the Second World War, the philosophers began to fight amongst themselves, and the world was torn apart.
The Cobras, my comrades who trained and fought alongside me, were torn apart as well.
The foibles of politics and a march of time can turn friends into enemies just as easily as the wind changes.
Ridiculous, isn't it?
Yesterday's ally becomes today's opposition.
And this Cold War?
Think back.
When I was leading the Cobras, America and Russia were fighting together.
Now, consider whether America and Russia will still be enemies in the 21st century.
Somehow I doubt it.
Enemies change along with the times, the flow of the ages, and we soldiers are forced to play along.
I didn't raise you and shape you into the man you are today just so we could face each other in battle.
A soldier's skills aren't meant to be used to hurt friends.
So then what is an enemy?
Is there such a thing as an absolute timeless enemy?
There is no such thing, and never has been.
And the reason is that our enemies are human beings like us.
They can only be our enemies in relative terms.
The world must be made whole again.
The philosophers must be reunited.
I will devote my skills to that purpose.
And with the colonel's money, I will achieve that end.
Just as I once created the Cobras.
They are my family.
The Cobras...
I may no longer be able to bear children, but I still have a family.
Cobras...
It was November 1st, 1951.
I was in the Nevada desert, participating in atomic testing.
The name Nevada is derived from Spanish.
Covered in snow, white as snow.
And snow is exactly what I saw in that Nevada desert.
It froze my blood white.
Snake, you were an atomic test subject, weren't you?
On Bikini Atoll.
That's part of the reason I was drawn to you.
You and I are alike.
We're both slowly being eaten away by the karma of others.
We'll never have the chance to die peacefully of old age.
We have no tomorrow.
But we can still have hope for the future.
In 1960, I saw a vision of the ideal future.
From space.
Three years earlier, the Soviet Union had succeeded in launching Sputnik, the first man-made satellite in history, into orbit.
This came as a huge shock to the United States.
In response, America threw everything it had into its own manned spaceflight project, the Mercury Program.
Even as the Soviets seemed poised to send their first man into space, America was still experimenting with chimpanzees and rockets.
Monkey!
The government wanted human data.
So they secretly decided to send a human being into space.
I was the one they chose.
At the time, they didn't have the technology to block out cosmic rays, and whoever they sent up would inevitably be exposed to heavy radiation.
That's why they chose me.
After all, I'd already been irradiated once.
Of course, you won't find any of this in the history books.
I could see the planet as it appeared from space.
That's when it finally hit me.
Space exploration is nothing but another game in the power struggle between the U.S.
and the U.S.S.R.
Politics, economics, the arms race... they're all just arenas for meaningless competition.
I'm sure you can see that.
But the Earth itself has no boundaries.
No East, no West, no Cold War.
And the irony of it is, the United States and the Soviet Union are spending billions on their space programs and the missile race, only to arrive at the same conclusion.
In the 21st century, everyone will be able to see that we are all just inhabitants of a little celestial body called Earth.
Earth.
A world without communism or capitalism, that is the world I wanted to see.
But reality continued to betray me.
In 1961, I was sent to Cuba, to Bahia de Cochinos.
It was part of a CIA-sponsored invasion, under the guise of taking Cuban exiles back to their country.
But the U.S.
government betrayed them.
Our weak-kneed president held back their air support.
Defenseless, the exiles were annihilated by the Cuban army.
All I could do was watch in silence.
I was set up by the very country I'd sacrificed so much for.
By the very government I'd dedicated my life to defending.
History lesson, yeah.
Everybody pay attention.
I was driven from the surface world, and I went underground.
Then, two years ago, I faced the Sorrow, my old comrade in battle.
He was my friend.
But one of us had to die.
I was left with no choice.
The Sorrow gave his life for me.
There is no enmity between us.
One must live, and one must die.
That was the mission.
The ones who gave me that mission were the philosophers.
Early in the 20th century, the true holders of power in the United States, the Republic of China, and the newly formed Soviet Union...
The secret pact they formed there marked the beginning of the philosophers.
But the last of the original members died in the 1930s.
After that, the organization began to run out of control, and the Wiseman's Committee degenerated into a mere shell of its former self.
Is that a child?
Is that her?
The philosophers of today have no sense of good or evil.
It's like a kid on the right.
Their influence extends to countries and organizations involved in every aspect of every war.
They have become war itself.
That's how they operate.
The sacrifices of war cause a shift in the times.
This shift leads to renewed conflict, and in turn triggers the next war.
Like a nuclear chain reaction, each conflict sparks countless others, forming an endless spiral that will continue on for eternity.
Do you understand what I'm saying, Snake?
By consuming me and you, the philosophers intend to keep that cycle going forever.
It was my father who explained all this to me.
He was one of them.
You see, I am the last remaining child of the philosophers.
But after he revealed the truth, my father was killed by that same shapeless, formless organization.
And my father isn't the only thing the philosophers have taken from me.
In June of 1944, the Cobras and I took part in the landing at Normandy.
We'd been given a top secret mission to locate and destroy enemy V2 rocket installations.
I was pregnant at the time.
The sorrow was the father.
I gave birth on the field of battle.
A beautiful baby boy.
But my child was snatched away from me by the philosophers.
Look at this scar.
This is proof that I was once a mother.
He was huge.
I gave up my body and my child for my country.
There is nothing left inside me now.
Nothing at all.
No hatred, not even regret.
And yet sometimes at night, I can still feel the pain creeping up inside me.
Slithering through my veins.
Through my body.
Like a snake.
I've never talked this much about myself before.
Thanks.
Thanks for listening to me.
I feel content.
Snake.
Commence the operation.
Go.
I raised you.
I loved you.
I've given you weapons.
Taught you techniques.
Endowed you with knowledge.
I love weapons.
There is nothing more for me to give you.
Every birthday I get a new weapon.
All that's left for you to take is my life.
No!
By your own hand.
One must die and one must live.
No victory, no defeat.
The survivor will carry on the fight.
It is our destiny.
The one who survives will inherit the title of boss.
And the one who inherits the title of boss will face an existence of endless battle.
I'll give you ten minutes.
Ten minutes.
In ten minutes, Migs will come and bomb the hell out of this place.
If you can beat me in less than ten minutes, you'll be able to escape in time.
Oh god, she's going to say one of my favorite lines.
Let's make this the greatest ten minutes of our lives, Jack.
Boss!
You're a soldier.
Finish your mission.
Prove your loyalty.
Loyalty.
Loyalty to the mission.
Face me.
Okay.
Get ready!
Wait, boss!
Boss!
Where am I?
Hold on.
Can I take you down?
Oh, she takes me down.
Hold on.
Put on sneaking suit!
You guys, I wasn't even going to start.
I was going to go to the bathroom.
Bathroom.
Oh, I don't have my CQC gun.
What am I using?
Oh, there we go.
I feel like this one...
We'll do the tranq.
We'll do a tranq one.
I have to go to the bathroom so bad.
Oh my gosh.
I've been having to go for like the past twenty minutes, but I can't let her not talk.
This one, I'll just let you guys know how it's going to take me.
Either a couple tries or definitely this first one is not going to be...
Is not going to be...
It's not going to be like a one and done because...
I like to hear...
I like to...
Rather, I want to like try and time it.
You know?
With the Snake Eater song, so...
Yeah, yeah.
What do I need?
Oh, bandage.
Broken bones.
Oh.
Oh, let me go pee.
One second.
Let me go to the bathroom real quick, guys.
And then...
We will do.
Also, I'm going to get some migraine medicine.
Because I feel that...
Like...
I'm on the tip.
It's like I have a headache right now, but I feel like it's going to turn into a migraine.
Like...
Any...
In like a couple of minutes.
So...
Give me a few minutes.
Here, I'll let you guys look at here.
Actually, before I forget...
Let me change my camouflage...
To...
Snow...
Face.
I don't...
I'm just going to do no paint.
Because I feel like...
I don't want to forget about it.
And if I do the cutscene, you know.
Okay, so give me a few minutes, guys.
And then we shall commence...
Final battle.
Okay.
BRB.
I'm also probably going to get some food.
So this is probably a good time if you have to get food...
Or do anything...
And you don't want to miss the fight...
To go do that.
So, yeah.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Sorry about the long, long wait.
Sorry about that.
Okay.
I got some food.
I just had to heat it up.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I wanted to get something to eat before I...
Before I...
Went into this.
Welcome back.
I'm back.
Okay.
And I needed more drink.
Yummy.
Gamer Supps.
I'm actually trying...
They send me so much Gamer Supps...
That I'm actually trying to get through it all.
So I'm like...
Okay, don't buy any...
No, don't buy any new tea.
Don't buy any new...
New anything.
I don't know if this is a glitch...
Or if there is multiple 50.
Thank you so much.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
I really, really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
My own personal survival.
Yeah, let me just fuel up a little bit.
I got some leftover taco stuff, so...
Yeah.
It's hot though.
It's hot.
Not a glitch.
They just gave me 200 members.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Holy moly.
Thank you so much.
I hate eating on my lap though.
Because...
The light...
Okay, so I have like a...
I have like a desk...
Like a RGB light under my desk.
But it like always illuminates my food in like a...
It doesn't...
It makes the food look so gross, you know?
Yeah, it's my RGB food.
It's like radioactive real.
But it makes it look so gross.
Especially when it turns purple.
Or like a purple-y pink.
It like just...
And it makes it look...
It makes everything look radioactive because of the colors.
Okay, I got a bite in, but I'm gonna be honest...
I'm just really wanting to do this fight, so...
And also it's really hot, so...
I'm gonna hold off for now.
Let's see...
Let's see how it goes here.
How was the fishing trip?
Good.
Very good.
Food looks good in yellow light.
Does it?
A lot of my lights are like the yellow-y lights.
I know some people hate it.
But...
And it's weird because I prefer like...
Bright, natural.
Like I prefer opening up all my windows and stuff.
But...
I feel like some of the super bright lights are just too bright.
It's not what I want at night especially.
Like at night I want...
I want it to be warm and, you know, make me feel tired.
And then in the day I just open up all my windows.
So I don't really ever need the super bright light.
You know what I mean?
The closer to natural sunlight the better.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Anyway, okay.
I'm probably gonna die here, but...
Oh my god, I just realized...
Oh my god!
Please!
Wait!
Can I not change the camera?
Wait, can I not...
Oh, shoot.
Not for this fight.
Oh my gosh, no way, really?
Oh, boss camera is fixed.
Oh, I don't remember that at all.
Okay.
How do I...
I just combatted her CQC, but I also don't remember how to CQC her.
Bandage.
And then...
Disinfectant.
What do I need?
Oh, suture.
Holding circle.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Where is she?
She's scaring me.
Boss?
I hear her.
She doesn't see me, does she?
Ah, I blew my aim.
Ah!
Holding circle did not work.
It's okay though?
I know!
Oh my god.
I'm trying!
Turning it down a little bit.
Where'd she go?
She's running.
Shoot.
Oh my god.
Oh gosh!
Oh no, dang it!
Oh come on!
Snake it up!
Oh my gosh.
Dodging that is...
Bone fractured.
What else?
Bandage.
Tap the moment you hear her grab you.
Okay.
Where is she?
Oh, there she is.
Take it.
Where'd she go?
Where'd she stop?
Don't go by there.
Shoot.
I missed her.
Flowers are in the way.
Get her, Snake.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna...
Actually use...
My mozen.
I don't know why I wasn't using it before.
Yeah, you have to...
Yeah, exactly.
Where'd she go though?
Was that her?
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe I saw her.
Where'd she go?
I'm expecting like her to just say five minutes left like any second now, you know?
Oh, there it is.
Oh gosh.
Where is she going?
Oh, I can't see anything.
Flowers.
Where are you hiding?
I found you.
I'm ready.
I'm gonna cry.
Oh, look at the snake up there.
Where'd she go?
Oh, I see her.
There she goes.
Where did she go?
Oh, I lost her.
Oh,
did I get hurt?
I can't tell actually.
Did I?
Oh my gosh.
Snake, please.
Snake.
Oh god.
This function just kills me every time.
I missed?
How is it twice in a row I missed?
It's okay.
Like I said, I...
Oh, whoops.
I am not like...
Being like, I have to defeat her this time, you know?
So no worries.
Oh, we're about...
I got her.
Crap, snake!
Here it is.
Where did it go?
With darkness and silence through the night...
What a thrill...
Where'd she go?
Oh, there she is.
I'm searching...
To melt into you...
Oh my god!
What a fear in my heart...
But you're so supreme!
Supreme!
I like being alive!
Not for honor, but
for...
In my time...
There'll be no one else...
I thought I heard her.
Oh, I do hear her.
Oh gosh, I can't see anything.
There you are.
In a dream...
Snake eater...
I'm trying to move!
Someday we'll feed on a tree frog...
Ordeal and trial to survive...
For the day we sing a lullaby...
Where'd she go?
I'd give my life...
Not for honor...
One more minute!
Ok, don't tell me that.
It's stressing me out.
In my time...
No one else...
Crime is the way...
I fly to you!
I'm still in a dream...
I'm about to die, actually.
Snake eater...
Did she dodge my attack earlier, I think.
I'm still in a dream...
Snake eater...
There it is.
Goodbye!
Honestly...
Maybe this is the better end.
Actually...
Oh,
it's changing.
Actually, I haven't let it change once this whole time, so...
Let's do it.
I'll snack while...
I'm paranoid.
Oh no, not paragon.
Ok, hold on.
Sorry, I'm eating this piece of chicken.
Give me a sec.
Oh my god.
She really just do be coming at me.
First thing.
Snow!
My backpack.
Let's do...
This.
Yeah,
I have life medicine still.
My thermal goggles.
Oh wait, I should have shot her there.
I'm so dumb.
I didn't realize she braked for so long.
Ok, good to know.
Where is she?
Where did she go?
Ma'am?
Mom?
Sorry, mom?
Ma'am?
Lady?
Where did she go?
Oh, I see her.
I thought I saw... Oh, there she is.
No!
Snake
run!
Snake run!
Uh oh, we are in a bad spot.
Because of the...
Wait, maybe actually...
Where is she?
Or am I hearing a snake?
What am I hearing?
Am I hearing her or a snake?
Oh, there she is.
I missed my shot.
There she is.
It's so quiet.
Makes me want to whisper.
Snake.
Where did she go?
She is running.
Running, running, running.
Did she see me?
Oh my gosh, she is like right there.
Oh my god.
Snake the shot!
Got her.
Oh my god.
Run.
Actually, maybe we are okay.
I hear her.
This way?
Maybe?
I heard her.
Maybe.
She is...
Somewhere?
Gosh.
It's so hard to see.
Oh, I see her.
This is a battle of the wits and patience.
Oh, there she is.
I think.
Am I crazy?
Oh my god.
Where the hell is she?
Guys!
Goggles?
Yeah, let's try them.
That's a snake.
That's also a snake.
You just call me pathetic and then you say he is good?
Which is it?
Yeah, which is it?
Oh my god.
Oh, shoot.
He is gone.
I'm just gonna...
Oh,
wait.
Gosh.
I forget that she has a break every time I do that.
Okay.
Let's bait her out.
Where did she go?
Is that her?
Yep.
Shit.
I gotta be faster.
I gotta take more risks.
Where is she?
Streamer, please.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
Oh, shit.
Ah, shit.
Okay, come here.
Dang it.
I did not...
I didn't get the combo, guys.
Oh my god.
No, snake.
Holy moly.
Broken bone.
And what else bandage?
Yeah, I can't use... I'm trying for a non-lethal kill if you're telling me to use other stuff.
I'm not gonna listen.
I'm not gonna listen to you.
Cause I don't wanna actually kill her.
Can
I get her from here?
Where is she?
Wasn't she just right there?
Lady?
Wait.
Where
did you go?
Where did you go?
I can't see anything.
Holy cow.
Where is she?
Honestly, this fight just exhausts me every time.
It doesn't make me be like...
I'm just exhausted every time.
Where are you?
Oh, there she is.
It is a cinematic fight.
Indeed.
Where'd she go?
Here?
I have, haven't I?
Oh boy.
Oh my god.
I can't...
Please be behind this tree.
Please be behind... Oh, there she is.
Okay, I got her.
Is that the legendary?
Oh my gosh.
I can't, I can't.
Oh, oh.
Where'd she go?
I don't think this is the run either.
Oh, there she is.
Did she leave?
I can't... I can't get her.
No, please.
No, no.
Don't make me...
Oh my god.
Please.
Got her, got her, got her.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Nice!
One more minute.
Oh my god.
I'm just trying.
I'm just trying anything.
I'm just... Come on!
Oh my god.
I can't even get a hit on her.
No, where'd she go?
Where'd she go?
No!
It's not throwing.
I don't know what... I'm just button mashing because I don't know what to do.
Come on!
Snake it out, please!
Please!
I tried to punch her.
She punched me back.
OK?
Man.
That was so close.
Not really in the mood for you guys.
OK?
Not really in the mood for you guys to...
rag on me so much.
Just, you know...
Sometimes I can play around, but sometimes I'm just...
There we go.
Yes.
OK.
And I'll shoot...Oh my god!
Wait, wait, wait!
You were supposed to be stunned for a second!
What happened?
What happened to my stun?
Oh my gosh.
What?
OK, what is the actual button?
So I'm not just spamming something.
If anybody...actually no.
Everybody is going to tell me different answers, so nevermind.
What?
Where?
Oh, I see her.
Oh, I saw her.
Pew!
Oh my god, I hate me trying to change the camera angle.
She's over here somewhere.
Wait, there she is.
Oh my god.
Got her.
With darkness and silence with an eye.
Oh.
Wait, where is she?
What a thrill.
Oh, there she is.
I'm searching and I'm melting to you.
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Snake!
Snake get him!
I'm trying!
You run first.
She's over here.
Oh shoot.
There you are.
As if I haven't been staying behind the same tree for this entire time.
No!
Oh god!
Get up Snake!
Snake!
I'm trying to move!
Oh shoot!
Can I get her?
Nope.
It was worth a shot I suppose.
Get her!
Nice!
Good job Snake!
Good job Watashi!
Nice!
Oh wait, you're coming back!
I think I'm down.
Get up Snake!
Oh my gosh.
Oh please, mommy.
Please, let me have a chance.
Let me have a fighting chance.
I love you.
Mommy!
Where is she?
Oh shoot.
Gotta let her not see me.
No, not...
How are you avoiding these?
No!
Oh please, please, oh please, please, please god!
I hate this fucking game!
Fuck you!
Behind the smallest tree ever?
Oh my god.
Why can't you shoot me but I can't shoot you?
This is such bullshit!
You're cheating!
You're cheating for real.
Where'd she go?
Oh there she is.
Oh fucking...
It's so frustrating because this is supposed to be such a cinematic emotional fight and here I am just being like, you bitch!
You bitch!
Come on, get up Snake.
Please, behind the tree.
Preferable, preferably behind... I don't even know where she is.
Oh my god.
How'd you see me?
Is it because I'm all bloody now?
Oh my god, ma'am.
Ma'am, you're so close.
Where'd she go?
Oh my god, just one hit left.
Ok, I'm gonna go in for it.
What a thrill...
With darkness inside...
Right now I'm melting to you...
Oh my god, what a feeling in my heart...
Where are you?
I'm trying to punch her.
Why do you mean it's not yours?
Why?
Oh shit.
Why me?
I'm trying!
I think I should have gotten her in that one hit though.
I can't believe she shoots on my bullets.
Where'd she go?
Oh no.
I got it!
I got her!
Someday you'll be on a dream road...
To survive...
For the day we see new light...
We did it.
Ok, now back to being sad.
Back to being sad.
The philosopher's legacy.
We did it but at what cost?
No!
Boss, no.
I don't want it.
This song kills me.
There's only room for one boss.
And one snake.
No!
Ok.
Yeah, if we wait long enough maybe...
The game will change.
Oh my
god, FPS.
Good luck, PS2.
If her horse shows up, I'm gonna lose it.
The horse is here.
Symbolism.
During the boss fight though...
More than Snake Eater, I think of...
Heaven's Divide.
Like the first couple lines of Heaven's Divide.
It ties in so perfectly with this.
It does.
Such a perfect song.
What a damn good game.
It's not over yet.
We still have one last mini boss.
Ah yeah.
Well, not really.
Snake is so poor.
Poor man.
I don't think...
Eva, please.
Eva, let him grieve.
Here he comes.
Being such a stupid cat.
You can relax now, Snake.
Not this goofy-ass smile.
We're not done yet, Snake.
What happened?
Eva, you said you could fly this thing.
I sure hope not.
Oh my gosh.
Let him in, Snake.
Let him in.
If he's cold.
If you're cold, he's cold.
That's a lot of big boy.
That's a lot of big, big boy.
Ew.
Oh my God.
They're so...
Two of...Oh gosh.
Two of them are just such boys.
No.
That stance.
Oh God.
He's always pointing at him.
We're not gonna make it.
Eject Eva.
I'm sure Ocelot knows how to fly this thing.
Now they're just playing.
Now they're just playing around.
Look at that.
Oh God.
He looks so excited.
They're just dancing.
Curling
fingers.
Oh my God.
He's smiling.
He's having so much fun.
Oh my God.
Eva's like, please take care of this.
She's like, please.
We are literally going to run into the mountains.
Oh my God.
The tension.
That scene is just...
Oh, it's so good.
God, it's so good.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, please.
So good.
Oh my God.
I'm gonna throw up.
I just ate.
I'm gonna throw up because I'm so excited right now.
He trusts him.
Okay, so it's in the left... Right?
It's in his left hand.
The one with the bullet.
But it's always fun to get the one in the right hand, right?
Yeah, I went get him when he smirks and I blamed you.
Which one should we go?
Don't say it, Ocelot.
You're gonna ruin my immersion.
No!
You are an Ocelot.
Adamska!
John!
I know you will.
Okay.
Alright guys.
Pick one up already.
Let's just...should we go for the right one?
No.
Which one?
Hold on, I'm thinking.
I'm observing.
Hold on!
I'm sniffing them.
Pick one!
Have you lost your nerve?
What are you doing?
Pick one up already.
Pick one!
Have you lost your nerve?
Which gun?
Left?
Right?
He is so impatient.
Alright, pick guys.
Pick, pick, pick.
Vote in the poll!
Kiss him.
If only.
Wait, why is it 50-50?
Wait you guys, it's 50-50.
What am I supposed to do?
Wait!
Oh my god.
Stop!
Okay, I'm gonna close it.
Let's see.
Okay, I'm gonna close my eyes.
I'm gonna close my eyes and whichever one wins, I'm gonna count down from ten.
Whichever one is more, I'm gonna do it.
Okay, so...
Ten!
Nine!
Eight!
Seven!
Six!
Five!
Four!
Three!
Two!
One!
Left!
Pick one up already.
What are you doing?
Oh my god.
It was almost 50-50.
It was close.
What if I don't shoot?
What are you doing?
What are you doing buddy?
Spin the gun!
No, I can't do it.
It's no good.
I can't do it.
Looks like your luck has beat mine again.
But why didn't you pull the trigger?
God, he says so much with no words.
Ah, well.
Until we meet again.
Yeah.
John.
Don't jump out that.
You'll die.
Oh...
What is wrong with you Azula?
You are going to die!
God, they're...
No.
I took too long didn't I?
I just couldn't... I couldn't let the moment end.
Eva gave up so that we would stop having a moment, you know?
Make sure to breathe boss.
I can't.
They took my breath away.
I never breathe.
I'm dead.
Oh my god, the awkward laugh.
Uh...
Oh
no.
Nix!
There's no way out.
What are we going to do?
Final boss!
Part 7!
Those things got to be armed.
It's no use.
There's no way we can outmaneuver them.
Uh oh.
Oh no.
Her
eyes are so wide.
Holy...
He's screaming at them.
Don't shoot!
My Robin T.
Titans.
His smile is just too much for me.
Codexed.
Well done, Snake.
The Migs disengaged.
Most likely under orders from Khrushchev.
Is this his way of helping us?
Who knows?
Maybe he didn't want things to get messier than they already are.
Or maybe he just wanted us to owe him one.
The important thing is, you made it out alive.
As long as Khrushchev is with us, I don't think they'll be coming after you.
It should be smooth sailing all the way to Alaska.
When did the whores have been bombed by the Migs?
They just never go through with the bombing.
That guy, he always keeps you waiting.
Snakes don't belong in Alaska.
You didn't mean to.
Yeah, this game always makes me feel terrible.
It's never like a celebratory...
Oh boy.
Wait.
Wait, I'm too... Wait.
Oh gosh.
Guys,
it's time for all of us to collectively third wheel.
I love this song though.
I can't go back.
I left America behind me.
You saved this country.
Did he shower?
Do you think he brushed his teeth?
He's got little bat wings in his teeth.
Or is it an invitation?
God, she's so beautiful.
Or a proposal?
Oh my god, she's so beautiful.
Oh, she's so beautiful.
I don't take orders from anyone now.
No.
I can't.
I can't watch.
She's so beautiful.
Oh my god.
We know you can see through that.
Okay, you got me.
You got me.
Throw
it in the fire!
Yeah!
They're just both so sexy.
Oh my god.
He opens his eyes.
Snake keeps his eyes open.
Oh my god.
And then the rest was in my fanfiction.
Pants on.
Link?
Not the apple.
Oh my gosh, imagery.
Symbolism.
What do you mean by that, Spank?
Here we go.
Dun-dun.
This poor guy.
Just...
He got a checkie.
Good morning.
The creepy music.
So creepy.
That's why she had that gun!
It was all a lie.
Eva!
Everybody is tricking me.
Not you too.
You said that we could trust you.
Eva!
You said...
I speaved.
He believed.
She lied.
Yeah, and he just kind of...
He just said the whole location.
That...
Is actually...is that ever explained?
Or did he?
Dun-dun-dun.
You guys...
We're not there yet.
What?
It's ok.
It's ok guys.
Don't worry about it.
We're almost there.
We're basically at the end.
Everything has gone according to plan.
Thanks to your help.
Oh, a snake.
I too am one of the philosophers.
I'm an agent of the philosophers, a graduate of one of their charm schools.
Charm schools?
She played us?
Oh, like a damn fiddle she did.
Back then, they were collecting children from all over the world.
As a result, I'm indistinguishable from a native-born American.
So it didn't surprise me when you and Volgin couldn't tell the difference.
But...
She knew right from the beginning.
She knew because before the war, she was at one of the philosophers' schools too as an instructor.
The boss was the only one I couldn't fool.
She was the only one who knew I was a fake.
Snake looks so good in that outfit.
She told me everything.
Why did she open her heart to me like that?
At the time, I couldn't understand it.
But now, I think I do.
Snake...
She wanted you to know the truth.
She chose me to tell you.
That's why she saved my life.
I've lied to you so many times, but not this time.
Did you lie about...
Saying that I tasted like a wild beast?
Eva!
Creepy.
Everybody...
Everybody falls in love with a legend.
But because I made a promise to the boss...
And I intend to keep it.
I just wanted you to know.
And...
You have to live.
Kazuhira...Eva...
Snake,
are you okay?
Snake...
Snake, are you okay?
I'm not okay, oh god...
Snake, listen to me.
No...
She didn't betray the United States.
No.
Far from it.
She was a hero who died for her country.
She carried out her mission knowing full well what was going to happen.
Self-sacrifice.
Because that was her duty.
Oh, it's so gross.
Oh, it's so awful.
My whole team, I hate them now too.
We're gonna get a little secret surprise you guys.
You are above even the boss.
No, I'm not.
I hereby award you the title of Big Boss.
How did you come up with that one, chief?
Out of the way, sir!
Oh my god...
Okay, time.
Back to being sad.
Oh my god, he looks around, he's like paramedic, sigint, major, you all knew!
You all knew!
Snubbed.
Then he held on to that grudge for the rest of his old life.
Someone like him to handle our top secret sneaking missions for us.
A man who combines the qualities of a soldier and an agent.
Shut up!
The boss's defection was a ruse set up by the US government.
It was all a big drama staged by Washington so they could get their hands on the philosopher's legacy.
You knew!
And the boss was the star of the show.
They planned it so that they could get the legacy that Colonel Volgin inherited and destroy the Shagohot at the same time.
Only a legendary hero like the boss could have earned Volgin's trust.
Finding out where the philosopher's legacy was hidden was to be her greatest mission.
Everything was going according to plan.
But then something happened that no one could have predicted.
Volgin being Volgin.
A nuclear warhead at Sokolov's research facility.
Khrushchev demanded that the US government provide proof that it wasn't involved.
They couldn't just abort the operation to steal the legacy.
So the operation itself was greatly expanded and revised.
The authorities in Washington knew that in order to prove its innocence they'd have to get rid of the boss.
And that one of their own would have to do the job.
The public couldn't be allowed to find out about it.
Not ever.
This, they concluded, would be the best way to keep the whole thing under wraps.
The boss wouldn't be allowed to come back home alive.
And she wouldn't be allowed to kill herself.
Her life would be ended by her most beloved disciple.
That was the way the government wanted it.
That was the mission she was given.
And she had no choice but to carry it out.
Her death at your hands was a duty she had to fulfill.
Out of duty she turned her back on her own comrades.
A lesser woman would have been crushed by such a burden.
The tainted disgrace will follow her to her grave.
Future generations will revile her.
In America as a despicable traitor with no sense of honor.
And in Russia as a monster who unleashed a nuclear catastrophe.
She will go down in official history as a war criminal.
And no one will ever understand her.
That was her final mission.
And like a true soldier she saw it through to the end.
But I think she wanted you, of all people, to know the truth.
She wanted to live on in your memory.
Not as a soldier, but as a woman.
But she was forbidden to tell you herself.
And that's why she told me.
Snake, history will never know what she did.
No one will ever learn the truth.
Her story.
Her debriefing.
Will endure only in your heart.
Everything she did, she did for her country.
She sacrificed her life and her honor for her native land.
She was a real hero.
She was a true patriot.
Khrushchev is ousted from power.
China conducts its first successful nuclear test.
Sigan joins ARPA.
U.S.
government conducts a study on emergency medical treatment.
The Department of Transportation lays the groundwork for the creation of the EMT system.
Eva disappears without a trace in Hanoi.
Paramedic establishes the nation's first paramedic system in Seattle, Washington.
Major Zero disbands Fox.
The United States accumulates the remainder of the legacy.
The U.S.
branch of the Philosophers changes its name to the Patriots.
Carrying on the traditions of Major Zero and the Fox Unit, Big Boss establishes...
Fox out.
The Les Enfants Terribles Project.
The sons of Big Boss are born.
I'm not going to mute it, but I'm going to turn it down just a bit.
Maybe it won't catch the copyright.
Uh...
God,
this ending just...
This ending just makes you feel so terrible.
Robert Atkin Downs was one of the soldiers?
No way!
Oh my God!
Kazuhiro Miller was with us this whole time!
KAIZ was there!
Man...
She gave her life for you.
It's at the end of the game...
That you realize the Snake Eater lyrics are...
Really...
About...
The boss.
You are a true major hit, boss.
Are you okay?
I'm okay.
Man...
Such a...
What a hug.
Let's have a collective group hug.
Actually, you guys can do that.
I'll stand over here and I'll watch.
Should we do Secret Theater?
I'll have to change discs, but...
Let me... I think I'll have to wait until...
Until it's over, maybe?
Rika Muranako is a part of this as well?
Interesting.
Gosh, oh my gosh.
We're gonna have to do this all over again when Delta comes out.
I don't think I'm ready.
But I'll have my...
New model.
So...
It'll be new and shiny.
New shiny Minto and new shiny game.
Congrats on beating MGS3 Subsistence.
It was great seeing you play on PS2 since so many of us experienced it years ago.
Here's hoping for some disc 2 action with Secret Theater.
Duel Vote and Snake vs.
Monkey sometime.
We can watch Secret Theater now.
Once it's over.
I feel so sad.
Snake toggle.
Another important timeline date.
2024 Mint...
Co-founds the sons and daughters of the Patreon.
True.
Giving Eva the noodles after curing her lets you view her in the...
Black bikini with sexy poses and cure...
Oh my god, I really...
I really...
I really screwed that one up, huh?
I feel...
Oh my gosh, I met so many of these voice actors.
Rowdy Reiko.
Is that Monkey?
Snake vs.
Monkey?
I feel though a lot of the same things in this game will be in Delta.
So...
Ape Escape 3 for Solid Ape Minigame soon.
You met some of the voice actors?
Yeah.
We don't get this theme anymore, but it still makes me...
Yeah, Chris Zimmerman!
Thank you for the playthrough, boss.
If I remember correctly, the DCI's office is on one of the upper floors of the agency building.
So Ocelot somehow climbed up way up to some tiny ledge just to shoot a snake.
No, he's pretty good.
Oh, Ocelot.
Oh, Ocelot, you...
This guy...
is the most...
This version of the song though makes me...
Like the guitar version.
Freaks a lot.
That guy is just... Oh, there's Rumble Roses.
Otacon is a...
Why is...
Why did they bring up Otacon here?
Cynthia O'Rourke!
Wait, I didn't realize Rika Muranaka did both songs.
No, no, no...
The guitar part reminds me of Snake Beam from MGS4.
Me too!
Me too.
We still have one last thing after the credits.
Then I'll switch out the CDs for...
For...
Oh my gosh!
Wait, I should have changed camos.
I got the snake camo from the boss, but I never got to see it.
Yes sir!
No sir!
The CIA is taking care of the boss themselves.
Ocelot.
I believe the White House will be satisfied.
Khrushchev is finished.
Your time has finally arrived.
Your time?
Yes, the American president is relying on us to keep a lid on the whole affair.
We've got him by the balls.
It should make a valuable trump card in future negotiations.
Yes, Chief Director, of course.
I'll keep the KGB informed.
Balls.
He's calling someone else?
He's calling someone.
Who else is he calling?
Yeah?
Moshi moshi?
Yes, it's me.
Ocelot!
Oh my gosh!
It's been forever!
How are you?
The boss has accomplished her mission.
I thought he was calling me.
The philosopher's legacy is now safely with us.
In America's hands.
Us?
Ocelot, you are Russian?
With this money, yes, the philosophers can finally be revived.
You are us.
The film we handed the Chinese was a fake.
Peking must be in an uproar right about now.
Eva...
I'm afraid so.
Only half the money has made it back to the United States.
The KGB must still have part of the legacy.
Yes, the weapon has been reduced to ashes.
The weapon...Shagohad.
That's right.
Groznygrad has been obliterated by the Davy Crockett we brought in as well.
Oh my god!
Yes, that was the boss' work too.
Speaking of which, I've obtained something from Granon that you might find interesting.
It's a revolutionary new nuclear attack system.
Perhaps it might just come in handy someday.
Yes, we have John...I mean Snake to thank for that.
Khrushchev believed it as well.
Yes, they bought our story.
I don't think they'll be making a fuss.
I can play as the first in there.
You know he's probably...he's probably like looked in the mirror.
Triple crossing them!
Triple!
Of course, I'm always at the CIA's disposal...Mr.
Director.
Mr. Director!
Snake Eater!
Jaguar?
What's a Jaguar?
Godombo does it again!
Adamska was Adam.
Yes!
Oh my gosh!
We did figure that out.
It's so obvious.
He's been speaking English the entire time.
Thanks for the feed Kuri!
Yesterday my heart was beating so fast, my smartphone registered as exercise.
Stop!
No way!
I'm glad we could meet, David!
Thank you.
Also Valkyrie, thank you so much earlier.
You're still my oshi, Maid Eater.
What's this special item?
Maybe you get it after a new game plus?
73 kills!
No!
What?
My river was clean you guys!
How did we go from 10 to 73?
When we left Garazinigrad...
It says human killed.
Not the fish killed.
Motorcycle sand.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you so much for the haka!
Thanks for playing and sharing the experience with us, Mito!
It was my first time and it was an amazing ride.
What a great game!
I feel kind of empty now though.
I know.
The characters and story were so good and Snake went through so much betrayal.
Everybody.
Literally everybody.
And that's just the whole story in all of Metal Gear.
Everyone is just taking advantage of Snake.
No matter what Snake!
It's so...
So frustrating for him.
He's a good guy, you know?
It just makes me so sad.
Thanks for the playthrough.
I hope that if you're there when Matara is playing, you can tell her not to re-chat after the boss fight so nobody tells her to pull the trigger manually.
Sorry for the anti-vaccinating vaccine.
Yeah, thank you!
I do...
Maybe want to be there for Matara's...
Playthrough.
Maybe.
Thank you so much for the ping!
Not only did you first try a bunch of bosses, you got a bunch of difficult non-lethal boss finishes.
You're pretty good and don't let anyone else tell you otherwise!
Thank you!
Thank you.
Let it through!
You are above even the boss.
I hereby award you the title of Freak Boss.
Everybody always exploits the himbo.
It's true.
Wait, but what does Jaguar mean for real?
I'm so curious.
Oh...
Usually I get like elephant, so I'm just like...
Don't spoil anything, but does Adam know who his parents are?
I...
Don't actually know if that was ever like explicit.
I don't actually remember if that's explicitly...
Mentioned.
I know it's implied who his parents are in Codec in this game.
But that's from other people.
It's not implied from him himself, so...
You know?
I thought it was a QR code for a second.
It does look like that, right?
Okay...
Jaguar get from 1 to 100 kills.
Get from 21 to 50 alerts.
Use from 0 to 40 continues.
I only had 11 continues you guys.
That's actually insane for me.
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you once again for another Metal Gear stream!
With every stream comes with new laughs and heartfelt moments.
You're pretty good!
Terisa welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
I'm so happy!
Wow...
What's next in the line up boss?
I think I might go into...
I might do some of the games I have never played before first, like...
Ghost Babble, Snake's Revenge, Metal Gear Solid Acid...
And then we'll go into 4.
And then... I don't know if I'm gonna play Portable Ops again.
I'll be honest.
I didn't really enjoy it before.
I think they both knew considering the way they acted around each other and Adam was the CIA contact for the boss originally.
I guess that would make sense.
Really fun stream.
You've been a shining beacon this week.
Thank you Taylor!
I really appreciate it!
There's a leech rank.
If you finish the game with a leech attack it's Snake.
No way!
If you ever think about how Ocelot snaps his bullet necklace before Snake jumps into the river, but in the last showdown it's on his necklace again implying that he got a new necklace to put the bullet on.
I mean, he got a necklace to begin with to put the bullet on, so the guy is already just a freak!
That bullet is for Snake!
God...
OK.
Let me go to the title.
New item obtained!
The Patriot.
Brown face paint.
National flag face paint.
I forgot you get the tuxedo.
I usually only drink my coffee cold with milk, but I bought that one cup hot and dark.
I quite like it now.
Thank you for the Godot cosplay.
It was so awesome.
Askem desert camo.
Desert tiger camo.
Flecktarn camo.
So many camos.
Thank you for the pink!
Thank you Donald.
Thank you so much for the streaming.
It's so fun seeing you freaking out over this game.
I can never not freak out over this game.
On my desk I have a little snake standy made by Raspberry Maddy.
I have my tiny big boss and then I have a revolver ocelot pen from Fangamer.
On my desk is all MGS3 stuff.
Even though it's like tied with MGS2 as my favorite, but...
As someone who can barely handle combat and noted clicking simulator old school runescape, I think you're pretty alright against gaming pink boss.
Thank you Avril!
You know it doesn't matter if you're good or not as long as you enjoy it.
Alright.
And that's the thing about Metal Gear is I don't feel like I have to be so so good.
I just love experiencing the story.
Like to me I never feel like, even though I love this series so much, I never feel like I need to become a pro at it.
Because I love it.
Like I feel like I'm so satisfied just kind of...
Especially because if I don't play it for a while and then play it again I feel like it's a new experience.
So it makes me even more excited than if I were to like learn how to speedrun through it or something, you know?
I
got it.
I gotta get the second disc.
Disc 2, Persistence.
Wait,
where did I put the case?
Oh, there.
There we go.
Oh, the nostalgia.
I know, right?
So now the secret theater should be unlocked because I beat the game, so...
Sound gave me a flashback.
Welcome to your nostalgia trip.
Sorry this super isn't related to the game, but when is the Minto plushie coming?
Last update about it was in August and I want to buy one.
Luke, thank you!
I'm glad that you are interested.
Oh my god.
As for when it's coming, it's still in production.
So I can't say exactly a specific date.
I hope soon because...
For basically... Oh my god, Metal Gear Online.
For like all of my merchandise.
Almost all of it.
I've kind of like prepaid for the amounts, you know?
So I'm like...
I'm like...
Man, I really hope I can put this out soon so I can make some money.
Hopefully get my money back.
Since...
Since a lot of it is...
Just is predetermined amounts.
So...
Hopefully I can...
Put them out soon.
One of them, the little Lego blocks, those are ready.
So those will be shipped soon to the warehouse that I'm gonna be using.
But...
Time to buy, buy, buy.
I'm gonna do my best to keep things as low price as possible.
For merchandise, I don't really care so much about making a profit.
I would much rather...
People be able to...
You know.
Oh my god.
People be able to get some fun merch, so...
Woah!
These locations are...
This is the best trailer ever.
Those boxes there are not suspicious.
All these people running around in their boxes.
I never got to play Metal Gear Online.
I would love to though.
I never got to play it though.
So sad.
What will you be pricing the bathwater at?
Subsist.
Well, you know...
I would like you to take the bath.
So...
Sorry, I know I could click out of this, but it's so fun watching.
Open sales at a PST-friendly time?
Because I know all the merch is still out.
I don't... I really don't think so.
Sorry, Rycom is so funny.
What?
This trailer is so awesome.
I don't think it will sell out.
Like, I have a good amount of stuff, you guys.
Like, I bought a pretty good amount of it, so...
No!
Why is he... Oh, the magazine.
Oh, they are all looking at it.
Is this... Is this Peace Walker?
Oh my god, it's the training.
On the beach.
Is he saluting them?
So cute.
Oh my god, get stick bugged!
This is so pink.
I can't.
Please, god, bring back Metal Gear Online in Delta!
Please, god!
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please!
Please do Metal Gear Online in MGS5.
There are so many emotes to do.
Ghostbusters?
Why do you have that?
The Ghostbusters.
That was a flamethrower.
No, I think that was a ghost vacuum.
Bust him, bust him.
But, like I said, I got a good amount of stuff, so...
I don't think it will sell out, like, immediately.
I think you guys will be okay.
Oh my gosh, please, Metal Gear Online, please!
Please come back with Delta!
Please!
As for your question about playing on the V, Metal Gear Online V...
I don't know, because it's not exactly the same.
It's like when you go to other people's mother base and you kind of like...
Fuck shit up, right?
It's not...
Kind of how it is.
But I want the true interactivity.
Oh, there's more than that, really?
Has actual MP.
There was an online competitive mode?
Is there still an online competitive mode?
It's traditional MGO stuff, not FOB infiltrates.
Oh, really?
FOB, FOB.
Should still be up.
Should we?
Would you guys want to play with me?
FOB, FOB.
Yeah?
I love being able to play with you guys in Peace Walker.
I want that.
I want us to be able to play Peace Walker together when we get to it.
I think I might honestly do the whole game with people instead of just the boss fights.
Because I've done the game before, so it might help us get through it a little bit quickly.
PC or PS4 for MGSV?
Maybe I'll do PC this time.
I want to be able to get some mods and stuff.
And be able to customize my music and everything.
I didn't get to do that since I played on the PS4 before.
So...OK!
Secret Theater!
I never got to do this myself because before I watched just the cutscenes, but look!
The beginning is the end.
Wait, what is...
OK, I see, I see.
Let's go!
From here.
I think we go from here...
Then here...then here...
Maybe?
Are you still...wait.
Maybe it doesn't matter.
Yeah, maybe?
I don't know.
OK, let's do it!
Made in the USA!
She's so crunchy.
This guy.
Are there any R1's in this?
Actually...
No?
OK, nevermind.
Thank you.
I can sit back and relax so much.
Let me type something here.
Oh my God!
OK, we beat the game!
Watching Secret Theater now.
Basashi.
I think Delta will have the Secret Theater.
I hope so.
They really seem to be making a faithful recreation.
But it's hard to say since the HD collection didn't have it, you know?
Horse.
Pira.
What the...
Who will gulp like that?
I can't eat the horse.
Paramedic!
Snake.
Stop right there.
Oh my God, maybe Snake will love Sushi.
Oh my God.
Don't make her mad.
What is this fever dream?
Cowabunga!
Yeah, yeah.
Oh,
that's why it's called Basashi.
Close call.
These are actually funny.
Yeah, they are!
They're so goofy.
These are actually so goofy.
I
only remember a few of them pretty well, so...
What was that?
Oh, Snake!
It took off his clothes!
That was a close call.
I like how you can even do everything in here.
So funny.
What?
These titles are so good.
There we go.
Oh no.
Should we save Raiden for last?
Tatiana.
Yeah, OK.
We'll save him for last.
I have to thank you for waking me.
Oh God, Grandpa!
Grandpa!
Oh my God, he is just there.
Oh my God.
Where is he?
Where is Waldo?
Oh my God!
He is just like me for real.
Don't touch him.
Hmm...
Oh my God.
It's basically point blank.
This is Minto if she was still alive and aged to an old granny.
Yeah.
Twice.
Please guard the sound.
It's so loud.
He's gonna see them kiss!
Oh!
That's it?
This far?
The end is better.
Oh my God!
Oh no, she looks too cool.
Can't kill her.
Grandpa!
Oh my God.
Does it keep going?
Oh, OK.
He still got it.
Yeah, we'll...Snake Erasure.
Eraser, sorry.
We'll save these two.
The MGS4 trailer also.
No, I'm gonna be...No!
The quick version.
I want the really quick version.
I think I remember how the trailer is.
Ocelot.
It's like kind of like...Oh my God.
I don't get to do this anymore.
It's like at the end of a movie when they had like the...
Like a cartoon movie when they had the cartoon characters do bloopers and stuff.
The joy.
OK.
DMC5 has some good ones?
Stop!
Yeah, like at the end of...Pixar, Pixar, Pixar, yeah.
That was genuinely funny.
The joy.
Is this the Rock, Paper, Scissors?
The new series has this, but it's not an after game thing.
It's joke endings you can get.
Oh my God.
They shouldn't be bothered.
Boss?
What?
Oh my God!
She explodes.
All of the cover unit explodes.
I read them for the articles.
This one is going to be a little sassy, isn't it?
Sokolove.
Sokolove you naughty naughty boy you.
What is this?
That's me reading my doujins.
Oh my God.
He's not even burning them.
He's stowing them away for later.
He's stashing them.
What is this?
He must be James.
He respects it.
Yeah.
Wow.
Those reflexes.
Snake is so cool when he's not mean.
When he's not controlled by me.
Snake?
You're not being a snake beater over here, are you?
His eyes!
Why are they so anime?
He should have shared.
Wow.
He did share.
Metal Gear...
Circle jerk.
No!
True bromance is sharing a magazine together.
If I find good stuff, I share with my friends.
That is the truth.
Mr. Siget!
He's just here!
Oh my God.
I almost spat on my drink.
When he did the smile.
You know what he looked like when he did the smile.
He looked like...
He looked like Sam!
From Rising!
Yeah, the Sam smile.
No, it should have been me.
Not him!
It was me!
Oh
no, Snake!
Oh no!
Oh my God, Siget is so cool.
The dogs!
Why doesn't he have a shirt on?
No!
Oh my God, Ocelot is not even looking at him.
Oh my God, this is me...
Wait, this is actually me playing as Snake.
This is how Metal Gear is when I play as Snake.
Oh my God, it's too real.
Game Snake vs.
Cutscene Snake.
No!
Oh my God, it's the same exact.
Wait, no way.
Oh, he's quivering little lips.
Snake, no!
This is cool, oh my God!
Self-insert fanfiction.
Is he the tiger rug?
Don't tell me.
Oh my God.
I'm scared.
Ok, good.
His hair!
Snake!
What is this?
Give Snake a shirt!
Somebody!
Metal Gear Signature.
These are too much.
They are so funny.
Die hard.
I'm a big fan of Metal Gear Saga.
I wish.
What
is this animation?
This is peak anime.
It really is.
Give what up already?
I was thinking Team Rocket is passing over me.
The ultimate weapon.
Wait.
Scissors.
Nothing beats scissors!
What
is this?
My sleep paralysis demon making me choose.
What do you choose?
He looks like an idol.
Come out, Jack.
It's over.
Snake!
I don't think that was over the top at all.
Snake cheated.
He cheated.
Alright, we got a couple more.
And then we'll do these two.
These are so funny.
Okay, let's play Metal Gear Solid 3 one more time!
My bag!
Colonel!
The beginning is the end.
Gotcha this time.
Get down.
Payback.
Cat like behavior.
Let's do gotcha this time.
Nice speedrun.
Thank you!
This one is so short.
This one.
This one is really...
This one is really peaking my curiosity.
I must be patient.
I still remember all of these.
They are so good.
I can't wait for the one with the...
This!
The guys from the end.
Oh my god!
Okay, wait.
Maybe it's not this one.
The one where the guy gets snubbed.
It's this one because it's payback.
Wait, this one is so funny.
Why were they all suck a lot?
What does get down have to do with it?
Okay, this one is good.
This is the one I remember the most.
It's so good.
It's so funny.
This is me playing!
The handshake, yeah.
Because he snubbed him in the end.
So funny.
Director of the CIA.
What are you doing here?
Wait!
I forgot that he...I didn't even remember him saying that.
So funny.
This one is so good though.
It's payback for not shaking his hand!
Look how mad he is.
He's like seething.
Oh my god!
CQC Pro!
He's like, take my hand!
What's so funny about this is just how actually absurd they are.
Some of these make actual no sense.
It's like, what if the guy who didn't get the handshake at the end wanted revenge?
And then, once he got the handshake, they kissed!
Kojimbo does it again.
Whose idea was the kiss, I wonder?
Little YouTube poops, I don't know.
Whose idea was the kiss?
I know!
You were like the first person I saw.
You're all good.
Thank you!
Thanks for coming to save me!
Thanks for the Haka Soup.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, let's find it and then we have two more.
Also, thank you for letting the other person borrow your other glasses, BiriBiri.
They told me.
I'll give you that.
It's not...this isn't a speech you would think would target my core like this.
Oh my God.
Oh, but it does.
Oh!
Bitch!
Gotta get that fourth one in.
Alright, let's watch this one.
Metal Gear Raiden.
And then we'll watch the trailer.
This is so funny.
Oh!
Rosemary.
Oh my God, look how smug he is.
I love this.
This is so funny.
Terminator reference.
Oh my God, look at him.
He looks so good.
The
necklace.
Did I kiss?
This game...this series is just...
Oh my God.
This series is too...just...
We've had more men kissing than...than anything else.
We saw Raiden kiss Ocelot before we saw him kiss Rose.
Oh Ivan.
His face.
Oh.
Stop.
Oh my God.
I can't.
Oh.
Raiden.
Raiden!
Oh my God.
This is so goofy.
The music is too much.
Brandon!
How mysterious.
What is happening?
There's two of them.
Oh my God, there's two of them.
Hello.
Ivan!
I was you with Matara.
What are you talking about?
Paradox.
Why does Raiden sound so weird?
Who's voicing him?
His NBA is Rycarl.
Interesting.
I guess it wouldn't be...it would be kind of weird to bring in Raiden's VA just for a secret theater.
Oh my God.
So loud.
He's so cool.
Don't you see Raiden?
This is why he's the main character.
You alright?
Sorry.
Gotta be careful out there Raiden.
Don't do it.
Don't do it Raiden.
No!
Let's go.
They went heavy on the eyeliner with him, didn't they?
Oh my God, I can't believe Raiden is dead!
Raiden!
Oh my God, even here.
Is he out the window?
Is he the one peeking in?
Imagine him in like a Spongebob style full body cast.
Stop!
Why would you do that Raiden?
You get your own game.
That's why he becomes a cyborg.
Oh my God!
No!
No way!
Stop it!
Oh my God!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, Big Boss!
Wait, this is Metal Gear 2 so this would be actual Big Boss.
Technically I guess.
Don't interfere!
He is mine!
I knew I should have killed you!
That's just the cut out of his head.
It's too funny.
There is going to be a 5, right?
Oh, about that...
About that...
Ripperoni.
Alright, now let's watch the trailer for MGS4.
Which I'm pretty sure this is all silly stuff too, but...
These are so goofy.
I'm so tired now though, so after this I'm going to call it quits.
Sleepy, sleepy.
No 5, only B.
Yeah.
He got his revengeance.
Kojima Productions!
Don't worry, Riot and Big Boss didn't start 5 either.
It hurts.
Oh my gosh.
I can't imagine being at E3 and this starting.
I would have just...I would have...
No place to hide!
No place for...
Stop.
Kojima Productions presents...
Snake, you gotta get the chair!
Snake!
You gotta get the...main character!
Bing!
Don't you dare.
No place for Hideo.
No hideout.
One chair left.
I love how this is a trailer for 4 and MGS4 is like one of the most...
totally sad games.
You feel so...
You feel so...no replacement for Hideo.
Is it riding?
I guess we should have watched this one before, huh?
The other one.
But that's ok.
But yeah, like you see this and you're just like...
Haha!
This is so silly!
Oh my god, no.
Sam.
Splinter Cell.
Sam Splinter Cell.
And then...it's just...
The fourth game is just way so depressing.
Oh my god, they're so cute.
That's me in the audience by the way.
I take that credit for every single one of those people in the audience.
Seats?
MGS4!
That explained...
Literally nothing about MGS4.
That literally...
For PlayStation 3.
Explained everything.
They show ridings in it, yeah.
Thank you.
PlayStation...I cannot believe the trailer for Metal Gear Solid 4 was in 2005!
Oh my god.
I mean, it wasn't the game came out with...
3 years later?
Oh, 7.
3 or 2 years?
Was it 2008?
Right?
I thought.
Some people are saying 2007.
But wow.
Even I'd say Metal Gear Solid 4's graphics really, really hold up.
The whole Metal Gear series...
I mean, I guess...
If you want to argue MGS1, but...
The whole Metal Gear series really holds up...
Graphically.
It just all looks so good.
Thanks, Splinter Cell Toss.
A couple of references to Metal Gear Solid.
If you interrogate guards, they go like, You can't shake me and have ammo fall from me.
That's so cute!
IMO, MGS1 holds up the best out of all of them?
Really?
I think so.
It does.
I mean, for the time, it looks great.
But, you know...
Like, I could suggest Metal Gear Solid 2 to someone...
And they could be like, Wow, this looks really good.
If someone is like, I hate old games.
I hate how they look.
You know, if someone were to say that...
It's really hard to say that Metal Gear Solid 2 looks quote-unquote old.
You know what I mean?
It's actually so...
I get...
Only...
Only I feel kind of recently...
I never used to feel this way.
But only very recently...
I mean, probably within the past two weeks...
Did I start feeling...
So...
I guess sad?
About how we'll never have such a golden age of video games again.
Like, in terms of technological leaps.
Like, only really so recently...
I was just like, oh...
You know, like...
Going from Metal Gear Solid 1...
On the PlayStation to Metal Gear Solid 2...
And the PlayStation 2 was like...
You know, I even still remember when I...
Like, watched the cutscenes...
Not the cut...
Like, you know, the...
Not the in-game rendered ones...
But like, the super nice ones in Kingdom Hearts...
And I was just like, this is...
This is the most incredible thing I've ever seen in my life!
You know?
I was like, wow!
Like, just watching those...
And how...
How...
You know...
I was able to see...
The progression...
So cool.
If you ever get sad about thinking that you're old...
Just know that at least you got to kind of experience...
That era.
You know?
And it's something that is very unique.
VR still has a ways to go at least.
That's true!
That's true.
Very, very true.
Imagine jumping from Sega Genesis to 3D models on the PS1.
That was young me, I know!
Just wondering, did you ever...
Play the Cyberwolf DLC in Metal Gear Revengeance?
Not the Cyberwolf, no.
I played Sam's, but not Cyberwolf.
PS2 was the best time period.
So good!
And I don't say that as just like...
My nostalgia!
But seriously, just the...
Graphical leaps we went through.
So awesome.
Hideo Kojima's humor has me thinking he can do Dragon Ball games slash stories...
Because it's very similar to Akira Toriyama's, in my opinion.
I can see it!
Oh my gosh, the new Dragon Ball game!
I've been watching clips of it...
That have been appearing in my Twitter timeline...
And I'm...
I'm dying!
It looks so fun!
It looks so...
It looks so funny too!
PS2 had Ace Combat, so it's automatically peak.
Yeah...
I don't know, I'm not gonna...
I say, I don't know.
I think only like until a couple of years ago...
Did it really just kind of...
Plateau.
We were doing well for a long time...
In terms of games and stuff.
But only in recent years did it kind of plateau.
Like I wouldn't say PS3 is better than PS2...
Or PS2 is better than PS1.
I think that whole...
Or even like Xbox or whatever...
Time frame was just awesome.
And now we're at where we're at, so...
I guess we'll see where games go from here.
Yeah...
We became too expensive to develop.
Oh my gosh, you have video games that are like...
With budgets of like millions of dollars.
Why?
It's crazy.
It's so crazy.
Hundreds of millions even sometimes.
Yeah!
GTA 6 is a billion dollars!
No...
No way.
There were millions of dollars back in the 2000s.
Two at least.
I guess...
I don't know, but it just like doesn't feel the same, you know.
Because I feel like they actually invested in...
In developing the tech...
Back then.
And nowadays it's like...
Hmm...
Do you guys want to see every grain of...
Dirt?
Please clap.
Anyway...
This was...
Fine, this is so much fun.
Thank you guys.
Exit the secret theater?
Yes.
Oh...
Trine Princess, thank you!
Thank you guys!
Duel.
Wait, what's duel?
Online mode.
What is duel?
Yeah, and there is also snake versus monkey.
Oh, boss fights.
OK, OK.
Boss rush.
Thank you guys for...
More...
For finishing Metal Gear Solid 3.
We'll take a little break in between the games.
Metal Gear Solid 4 will do a number on my heart.
So I need to prepare.
Probably I won't do any more Metal Gear until after my new model.
But then I'll do, like I said, Ghost Babble and Metal Gear Solid Acid.
And Snake's Revenge.
And all the games that I haven't touched, the older ones.
I'm not very much looking forward to Acid.
I might change my mind about when I'll play it.
I might just do Ghost Babble and Snake's Revenge and leave Acid for another time.
Who knows?
But...
Since it's spooky season, you gotta play some spooky games.
I know!
I know, I know, I know.
I have lots of spooky games coming up.
And some non-spooky things, but some spooky adjacent things.
Coming up this week and next week.
And then after that...
Oh wait.
No, no, no, no!
And then after that I have my 3.0!
Thank you guys for Metal Gear Solid 3.
And remember to always stay loyal to the mission!
Otsuminta!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Schedule for this week might be a little bit delayed, but I am streaming on Monday, tomorrow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm finalizing something for this weekend.
But, uh...
Yes, and...
Oh wait, actually, well I am still finalizing it for this weekend.
But yeah!
Otsumita!
Thank you guys!
Congrats again, Big Boss!
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
Yeah, we did it!
Woohoo!
I will see you guys next time!
Itterasshai!
Bye bye!
Thank you!